[Musique]
Maxi Brena. Bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Bah déjà, merci à Finkerview de m'avoir
invité. Je suis très content. Merci à
toi Sky. Je peux mettre un visage sur un
sur un nom.
Et donc c'est une chaîne que je suis à
peu près depuis un an et demi. Et donc
en fait donc je m'appelle Maxime
Renaille, j'ai je suis auteur d'un livre
qui s'appelle Là où il est l'argent,
donc édité chez les Arènes qui est sorti
en avril 2019 et qui parle en fait de
mon témoignage enfin qui est mon
témoignage dans la finance offshore à
Jersy puis au Luxembourg donc dans un
cabinet d'avocat puis ensuite dans une
grosse banque américaine et en parallèle
donc je travaille je renseignais les
services secrets français donc la la
DGSE
de 2007 à 2012 et je l'ai fait de façon
bénévole en tout cas pour pas pour mon
travail mais en tout cas pour renseigner
la DGSE
et depuis euh donc j'ai aussi lancé une
plateforme avec mon frère Alexandre donc
la plateforme s'appelle
lanceuralerte.org
donc en un seul mot s lanceuralerte.org
org qui a pour but de révéler des des
affaires sur des milliardaires français,
des multinationales, des politiques et
de partager ces informations avec le
grand public qui est aussi des médias
médias alternatifs. Et on a commencé
aussi euh à attaquer juridiquement
certaines multinationales avec mon frère
via lanceuralerte.org.
Euh
bon, on se détend, on va on va
on va on va faire les présentations plus
gentiment.
Quel âge ?
J'ai 40 ans. 41 ans, pardon.
41 ans. Originaire de Bezack.
Euh c'est une région qu'on connaît bien.
On leur passe le bonjour d'ailleurs. Des
gens absolument formidables là-bas.
Ouais.
Euh euh donc on va se tutoyer.
Ouais. Sûr.
Donc je crois que tu es un des seuls
gars que je puisse connaître qui n'a pas
été tamponné par les services. C'est toi
qui les a approché. Oui,
parce que tu t'es rendu compte dans ton
activité professionnelle que il y avait
des choses qui se passaient et que tu
avais envie de de communiquer ces ces
informations pour l'intérêt général et
pour ton pays dans le bon sens du terme
parce que tu trouvais ça quand même
ahurissant. On va faire attention parce
que comme on est en direct, on va éviter
toutes les diffamations et tout ça.
Ou très attention. Ouais.
Euh on on va commencer le début de
l'interview par ton expérience avec les
services, ton expérience avec le monde
financier. On va rentrer un peu plus
dans le détail. Prends tout ton temps.
On a le temps ici. Donc no stress,
relaxe, respire profondément, tout va se
passer. Bah normalement, ils ont dû te
former la DGSE pour pouvoir avoir un
interrogatoire qui se passe bien. Non,
non, pas sur l'interrogatoire. Non, non.
D'accord. Bah, on va pas on va poser
tout de suite cette question.
Quel type de formation les services
t'ont dispensés pour faire de
l'interception de renseignement ?
Alors
et et avant de te je te repose la
question parce que en écoutant en fait
ton parcours, j'ai j'ai il y a quelque
chose que j'ai pas réussi à saisir.
Tu étais honorable contributeur ou agent
de la DGSE ? Alors euh
en fait dans les les agents secrets en
fait, tu as les les fonctionnaires donc
les officiers traitant que je voyais de
façon très régulière, mon officier
traitant qui j'en ai eu cinq durant
toutes ces années. Et euh dans
l'imaginaire grâce au film, à Hollywood
et tout ça, on pense que l'espion c'est
uniquement le fonctionnaire de d'État.
Or l'espion, bah c'est celui qui
espionne, c'est aussi c'est le
fonctionnaire d'État évidemment
l'officier traitant mais c'est aussi
celui qui espionne pour l'officier
traitant. Donc moi l'espèce j'espionné
pour la DGSE euh mais je n'étais pas
fonctionnaire de l'État. Donc pour
répondre à ta question, j'espionné pour
la DGSE mais je n'étais pas
fonctionnaire.
Euh honorable correspondant euh alors
c'est vrai que ça peut se poser la
question puisque je n'ai pas été payé,
j'ai pas demandé à être payé pendant
toutes ces années. Je ne voulais pas
être payé. Euh
mais un honorable correspondant il
comment dire ? Il il donne un
des infos de façon régulière mais il
participe pas à des actions plus
précises. On peut en parler plus tard.
Par exemple, quand la DGSE cherche à me
remplacer au sein de la banque dans
laquelle je travaille au Luxembourg, ce
type d'opération se fait euh comment
dire ? C'est c'est de l'espionnage pur.
C'est pas tu fais pas tu montes pas une
opération comme ça avec un honorable
correspondant. Euh et puis comme on
sûrement on on développera aussi
on a une relation forte qui s'est
développée entre mes officiers traitant
femme et homme durant ces 5 années.
Qu'est-ce que tu appelles une relation
forte ? Tu t'es fait intoxiquer pour
être serviable ?
Non pas du tout. Non en fait il y a une
camaraderie qui qui s'installe. Il y a
une confiance qui s'installe avec eux.
Euh et puis surtout il y a le fait, je
pense hein, enfin c'est ce qu'il m'ont
dit en tout cas euh plus tu travailles
avec eux, plus tu récoltes
d'information, plus tu deviens
technique, plus il y a une sympathie euh
euh une camaraderie de de fond qui qui
s'impose,
qui se qui se manifeste comment ? Vous
allez voir des pots, il vient bouffer
chez toi
ou non, pas jusque là. Non, c'est
segmenté la DGSE, c'est pas non plus de
l'amateurisme. C'est-à-dire l'officier
traitant, même s'il va être très proche
de toi, si
dans quel sens ? Et ben, il va par
exemple quand tu le vois à Paris euh tu
euh je fais faire attention à ce que je
veux dire parce que euh disons il tu
partages du temps,
tu partages du temps avec lui. Euh
tuéchanges des informations même très
personnelles en fait euh concernant tes
amis, ta vie avec les
la
et eux qu'est-ce qu'il donnent ? Alors,
je devrais peut-être pas le dire, mais
disons, je l'ai pas mis dans le livre,
mais sans sans sans vouloir les embêter.
Bah, il ils donnent aussi des éléments
de leur vie privée, en fait. Vérifiable,
je pense. Oui. Oui, vérifiable, oui,
que tu as cherché à vérifier.
Non, mais vu ce qu'il me disait, c'était
totalement vérifiable.
Est-ce que tu penses que tu as été
instrumentalisé par les services ?
Non, non, je pense pas. Je je pense
qu'il y avait une relation assez saine
où donc pendant 5 ans,
j'avais euh comment dire en en fait je
mon travail c'était c'était il y avait
trois axes, c'est-à-dire un, il me
donnait une liste qui s'est technicisé
d'année en année, ce qu'ils appelaient
la liste de courses avec des éléments
très concrets
que tu devais aller chercher que je
devais aller chercher pour eux donc à
Jerset puis ensuite au Luxembourg. Euh
après, moi je devais aussi euh, ça
c'était moins important, mais trouver
des profils qui pouvaient les intéresser
euh qu'ils auraient pu ensuite enfin
recruter. Mais ça c'est pareil, je ne
savais pas les tenants et aboutissement
des recrutements. Donc il fallait que je
je trouve des francophones ou
francophiles qui pouvaient être
débauchés pour la DGSE pour espionner
pour créer un réseau sur Jerset puis
Luxembourg.
Euh et puis la troisième chose c'était
ben j'avais
comment dire c'était carte blanche pour
récolter un maximum d'information euh
parce que je le dis souvent mais on
pense que les services secrets comment
dire sont omni omnipotents comme l'État
français mais qu'ils ont des systèmes
d'écoute énormes électromagnétiques.
Et rien ne vaut en fait le renseignement
humain sur sur place pour collecter des
choses qui peuvent intéresser les
services. Comment tu faisais pour tisser
un réseau sur place ? T'approcher les
gens à leur place et toi qui les
tamponnait.
T'identifier des profils ? Est-ce que tu
identifiai des profils plus faibles,
moins faibles ? Des gens avec des
failles ou des gens cupides ou des gens
patriotes ou des gens
Non, sans failles en fait. Les failles
ne ne m'intéressaient pas. Je je en fait
ce qui m'intéressait c'était euh des
gens qui qui avaient le plus le plus
d'informations possible tout simplement.
Pour moi, c'était euh j'ai j'ai repéré
assez vite si tu veux que le personnage
central de des paradis fiscaux,
contrairement à ce qu'on croit ou ce
qu'on sait, c'est pas le banquier,
c'est l'avocat. Et donc dès que j'ai
compris que c'était l'avocat qui était
le maître dans les paradis fiscaux, je
me suis euh infiltré dans toutes les les
réceptions, les réunions, les copinages.
Euh
comment ? Euh alors au départ euh
beaucoup avec les femmes évidemment, ça
a été la voix royale. Euh j'ai eu cette
chance-là. euh beaucoup de d'avocates
qui m'ont fait rentrer euh euh dans des
soirées, notamment le deuxème grand
cabinet d'avocat de l'île qui s'appelle
OG ou dans d'autres cabinets d'avocats.
Je euh donc c'est par les femmes par
ensuite des amis, les expats, beaucoup
d'expates euh qui venaient d'Afrique du
Sud, Nouvelle-Zélande,
Irlande et cetera. Et euh
donc là, c'était chercher plus alors il
faut savoir que les autres euh comment
dire euh job très intéressant dans les
paradis fiscaux, c'est ensuite les
experts comptables. Donc c'était les
deuxièmes personnes, le profil de
personnes que je recherchais. C'est
aussi ce qu'on appelle les gens qui qui
s'occupent de la KYC, donc c'est-à-dire
enfin en anglais KYC qui s'occupe de de
vérifier les informations si tu veux.
C'est une sorte un peu de police au sein
des en interne des banques et des et des
cabinets d'avocats. Donc ces gens-là,
les KYC,
il centralise énormément d'informations
sur tout le nouveau business qui arrive
sur l'île et aussi l'ancien business qui
passe en revue pour voir si c'est entre
guillemets pseudo légal ce qui est ce
qui est géré
euh par les par les cabinets d'avocats.
Donc c'était voilà, je c je centrais sur
déjà les professions. Ensuite, est-ce
que je m'entendais bien avec telle ou
telle personne ? Euh est-ce que ces
personnes avaient des portefeuilles très
importants ? Et ensuite,
c'est quoi très important ?
Bah par exemple,
il y a c'est dans dans chaque métier, tu
en as qui sont très forts et qui ont un
portefeuille, je sais pas, de avec une
trentaine ou cinquantaine de clients et
puis il y en a qui sont qui sont des des
ronds de cuir de la finance et qui vont
avoir 5 si clients qui sont pas
importants.
Des baleines, non ?
Exactement. Des baleines. Euh donc ça,
tu repères assez vite puisque dans ces
mondes, le monde de la finance offshore,
il est très petit. Donc tu sais très
vite qu'un tail il c'est un super
travailleur, qu'il a un portefeuille de
malade, qui fait vachement d'argent. Bah
évidemment tu vas aller vers lui, tu vas
lui payer une binous, tu
tu vas lui payer un petit rail. Non non,
pas de pas de drogue. Moi je me suis
jamais drogué et puis non mais
pas de [__]
Non pas de [__] non certainement pas de
prostituée. Non pas du tout. Euh non,
c'était des choses très simples en fait,
vraiment avec des moyens extrêmement
simples
de convivialité, de sociabilité, de voir
les gens. Et il faut savoir, alors ça
peut paraître gros comme ça, euh mais il
faut savoir que quand vous êtes dans un
milieu fermé, que ça soit une île comme
Jerset ou la finance offshore en règle
générale Luxembourg, quand vous êtes
entre personnes du même métier, les gens
dès que vous mangez, vous sortez, vous
allez en boire en boîte, ils vous
parlent de de de leur boulot, de leurs
clients, de ce qui va arriver. Euh donc
vous apprenez énormément de choses et ça
c'est en plus de ce que je collectais
dans mes lieux de travail parce que donc
le lieu de travail dans lequel j'étais
qui était le plus gros cabinet enfin qui
est toujours le plus gros cabinet de
l'île c'était 600 employés donc vous
baladez dans à l'époque il y avait pas
beaucoup de quand j'ai commencé en 2007
il y avait pas beaucoup de sécurité donc
je pouvais me balader vraiment un peu
partout et récolter des infos
avec ta tête en plus de de gendre
parfait
ouais enfin
ça passe bien he
de type sérieux Ouais.
Les informations que tu faisais
remonter, tu les faisais remonter
comment ? Par chiffrement, par contact
physique ?
Alors, chiffrement euh Oui, c'est-à-dire
j'ai reçu assez vite, on pour en
reparler aussi plus tard, une clé USB
qui était cryptée,
chiffrée.
Chiffrée, voilà. Chiffrée. Euh, je
remplissais, alors j'en parle dans dans
mon livre, c'est-à-dire j'avais reçu une
petite formation par un informaticien de
la DGSE qui m'avait dit
"Ça s'est passé où
Alors ça s'est passé dans un hôtel à
Paris, un un petit hôtel des
appartements qui se louent à la semaine.
Donc j'ai reçu une formation de 3 jours
là notamment apprendre ce que un de
faire un un itinéraire pardon de
sécurité euh donc vérifier les filatures
et cetera puis aussi avec
l'informaticien.
Comment on fait pour vérifier une
filature ? Alors là, ça serait compliqué
à à rentrer dedans, mais euh j'ai été
formé par un un autre agent euh euh de
la DGSE, un espèce de géant que
j'appelle petit gens dans dans le livre,
qui est un type extrêmement sympa, euh
qui était un ancien parachutiste et
également un comment dire, un plongeur
de de combat, vraiment le un type assez
exceptionnel. Et euh bah on a passé 2
jours enfin presque 3 jours de 2 jours
et demi à à voir dans Paris. Euh alors
il m'a déjà montré ce que c'était qu'un
itinéraire de sécurité euh comment en
créer un euh et puis ensuite il m'a
demandé d'en d'en faire un et
voilà.
Ça va ? Tu passes par les parkings, tu
rentres dans le métro.
Oui. Voilà. Pardon. tu passes tuas dans
les dans les passages parisiens, tu
apprends en fait, tu vois euh tu
apprends, moi j'ai sidéré, tu apprends
vraiment véritablement à regarder la
ville autrement, quoi. C'est-à-dire
chaque
chaque escalier, chaque vitrine de
magasin euh
chaque recoin devient un moyen si tu
veux de de voir si tu es suivi ou non ou
de ou de ou de ou comment dire ou de
permettre de t'échapper et de donc ce
cette personne qui m'a formé c'était
c'est un vrai savoir-faire qui existe
depuis depuis la résistance en fait
parce que c'est ce qu'il m'a dit c'est
c'est pas eux qui l'ont inventé c'était
déjà là avec
la résistance et donc il m'a appris ça.
Donc revenons à notre clé de chiffré.
C'était chiffré avec quoi ?
C'était chiffré comment ? Est-ce que tu
avais une bécane sécurisée qui n'était
dédiée que pour ça ?
Non. Alors c'était une clé chiffrée que
j'ai gardé en fait il y en avait deux
quand j'ai
nous l'amener.
Ouais. Enfin bon, je pense pas qu'ils
vont être très contents, mais bon. Euh
euh donc il y en avait deux en espèce de
d'inox aluminium en fait. Donc c'est
vraiment tu vois 2007 c'est c'était
vraiment et euh et en fait si tu si tu
tapes je sais plus cin ou six fois mal
voilà ça ça s'auto détruit enfin
l'intérieur est détruit et le formateur
m'avait dit tu ne tu ouvres la clé tu
ouvres notepad donc pas surtout pas Word
et cetera parce que c'est super
dangereux on sait pas avec les
Américains. Donc ça c'est en 2007 bien
avance noun bien avance qu'on a su avec
le programmes de la NSA. Tu mets Notepad
et tu enregistres pas le Notepad, le
fichier Notepad sur ton ordinateur mais
directement sur la clé USB chiffrée et
tu rentres tout simplement tes données
au maximum. Donc euh moi je remplissais
quand je piquais pas. Alors, soit je
piquais des informations en dur, donc là
je faisais des photocopies et puis je
les filé à mon officier traitant et où
je je rentrai les informations sur la
clé chiffrée
pendant ces ces ces années. Alors quand
j'ai commencé avec le formateur, il on
avait deux clés. Il m'a dit "À chaque
fois que tu en rempliras une, tu nous la
rendras et nous on te filera l'autre qui
est qui est vide." Et donc c'était un
échange à chaque fois avec l'officier
traitant.
Donc la remontée de données se faisait
dans Paris. Vous communiquez comment ?
Vous avez un 1 heure un jour précis ou
c'est quand je voulais Alors alors
c'était le téléphone tout simplement. Il
faut savoir que les officiers traitants,
ils ont
ce que j'ai vu, ils avaient deux deux
téléphones avec eux. Ils avaient leur
perso et puis ils avaient un un
téléphone portable
spécifique et j'avais leur téléphone
portable. Donc j'ai j'ai gardé les
numéros de téléphone
de de ces donc je les appelais
directement et eux m' me contacter
directement sur alors ça a pas été tout
de suite les premiers mois. Les premiers
mois c'était par email et dès qu'il y a
eu la confiance qui s'est instauré qui a
qu'ils ont été contents de mon travail
on est passé directement au téléphone ce
qui peut paraître ahurissant. Donc
c'était est-ce que est-ce que tu peux
venir dans 15 jours, tel jour, à telle
heure, à tel endroit, enfin pas à tel
endroit, l'endroit que tu sais.
Ouais, c'est comme ça que ça se passait.
Ça durait combien de temps
le débrief, tu veux dire ? Ouais,
débrief, ça peut durer le temps d'un
Ouais. 2h ça peut durer 2h s'il y a pas
grand-chose si il y a aussi de temps en
temps enfin pour les petites anecdotes
un officier traitant qui est qui est qui
doit aller voir un autre
qui a d'autres choses donc ça peut durer
1 heure 1h30 mais en général 2h et puis
des fois plus si si nécessaire
une petite enquête de proximité je pense
parce que tu les as contacté par en gros
le standard téléphonique des ministères
des armées non
oui oui c'est ça
ils ont fait une petite enquête de
proximité sur toi ils t'ont dit ce
qu'ils faisait ils t'ont ils t'ont tenu
au courant. Ils t'ont validé au bout de
combien de temps ? Ils t'ont ils t'ont
testé, ils t'ont pas testé ?
Ils m'ont validé, je trouve très
rapidement. C'est-à-dire entre le moment
où je les ai contacté où j'ai vu la
première personne qui allait devenir mon
officier traitant
euh ils avaient déjà fait l'officier
traitant enfin la personne qui devenir
mon officier traitant m'a dit tout de
suite je le mentionne dans le livre j'ai
il m'a dit très ouvertement on sait ce
que fait ta sœur comme boulot ton
frangin ton père on sait en gros ce que
tu as sur ton compte en banque enfin mon
pauvre petit compte en banque. Ils
savaient, il y a pas de souci, il
savaient, ils avaient fait une enquête
euh, je vais pas dire de voisinage, mais
ils savaient à qui ils avaient affaire.
Euh
historique de porno
euh
il savait il savait il savait plein de
choses. Il savait la personne que je
fréquentais à l'époque, pour quel
cabinet elle travaillait. Ils savaient
beaucoup de choses mais ce qui est
normal, ils ont des capacités.
C'est facile quand même.
Oui, c'est facile. Très facile.
Euh donc il y avait cette petite enquête
euh une fois qu'il y a eu cette première
rencontre qui s'est faite à Paris euh
près de de Notredame de Laorette
d'ailleurs. Euh
en fait ça, j'ai commencé à travailler
avec eux très rapidement. Je peux plus
te dire quand exactement, mais ça a été
une question de plusieurs semaines. Euh
et comme ils ont été, je pense assez
contents de la première moisson
d'information, bah alors là c'est parti.
Et puis avec les années, ils ont fait de
plus en plus confiance. Donc ils m'ont
fait de plus en plus de demandes. C'est
eux-mêmes se sont je dirais plus
professionnalisés sur l'intelligence
économique, sur le renseignement
économique.
Ah bah il est détant.
C'est un peu le parent pauvre.
C'est toujours le gros parent pauvre.
Tu connais le proverbe. Non. Il y a
intelligence économique et l'économie de
l'intelligence. Non. Non.
Ouais. Ouais. Ben oui, là c'est
à côté des pays anglo-saxons, on est
complètement à la ramasse. Bon, ça c'est
j'enfonce une porte ouverte évidemment
malheureusement encore aujourd'hui on le
voit
c'est l'impuissance de notre état
en tout cas des politiques parce qu'on a
tous les moyens pour pour faire face
pour être une grande nation de
l'espionnage en terme de d'espionnage
économique, c'està-dire défendre nos
intérêts. Pas
parce que les Français sont beau gosses,
ils sont faciles, il rentrent
facilement. C'est ça.
Non non non, ça rien à voir avec ça.
C'est Non, je pense qu'il y a il y a il
y a une forme de comment dire euh il y a
une forme de cohésion qui peut avoir en
France et d'intelligence dans différents
différentes
savoir.
Alors pourquoi on l'est pas ? Je pense
véritablement qu'il y a un problème
politique. Enfin, je veux pas tout
relancer sur les politiques, mais euh
c'est ce que j'ai
euh c'est ce que j'ai j'ai enfin je
pense véritablement parce qu'on a on a
des vrais gens euh enfin la DGSE, pas
forcément les gros boss mais les
officiers traitants sont exceptionnels.
Ils ont ils ont sont des très grands
généralistes.
qui sont capables de passer euh euh sur
un dossier de d'armement, un dossier de
rétrocommission qui passe dans les
paradis enfin à la à le comprendre. Euh
ils ont Moi, j'étais extrêmement
impressionné, je te le dis, par leur
leur savoir-faire et et leur
connaissances.
Alors, qu'est-ce qui pose problème avec
les gros boss ?
Je sais pas, je pense les gros boss, bon
je pas encore décri polytechnique avant
tout le monde un peu le fait mais
malheureusement
ces gens qu'on voit qui dirigent les les
administrations et donc aussi la DGSE et
cetera, les services de renseignement,
ils sont dans les mêmes promotions que
ceux que j'ai vu qui géraient les fonds
les fonds de pension, les fonds de
private equity, donc de la finance
offshore et tu vois plein de
polytechniciens qui sont à la tête de
fond de fond euh financier. Donc c'est
du pantouflage.
C'est c'est clairement du pantouflage et
du rétroantouflage. C'est-à-dire tu vas
par exemple aussi avoir un type qui a la
tête d'un fond qui au bout de 10 ans se
dit "Oh tiens, je vais passer 5 ans à
Berse 5 ans à Berte Bercy vraiment. Puis
après il revient à nouveau dans un fond.
il va être encore plus promu parce que
ça lui facilite ça lui facilite la vie
pour lui et les actionnaires. Ça lui
permet de voilà de avec le verrou de Ber
bon même s'il a été aménagé depuis euh
de passer entre les gouttes.
C'est c'est pas bien d'avoir un mec euh
qui est formé peut-être par les services
et qui va un peu traîner ses oreilles en
tant que grand patron de fond pour faire
remonter de l'information ou c'est pas
du tout le cas ?
Ça je peux je peux pas te dire là. Tu tu
me demandes si tu tu penses que
déjà vu passer ça. Non jamais.
Alors disons,
ouais, je veux peut-être pas trop parler
de ça en fait.
Tu es mal tombé là.
Ouais, je suis mal tombé mais disons on
va dire sans rencontrer. J'ai entendu
oui une personne dans la finance à un
gros poste
qui qui travaillait pour la DGSE. Donc
il y a pas que des méchants à la tête de
de fond d'investissement.
C'est ce que je voulais entendre.
Voilà. Facile hein ?
Ouais, facile. Bien vu.
Et euh je vais te reposer une question
après pour on on va commencer à rentrer
dans le dur. Là, c'est simplement
l'apéritif.
Ouais. Ouais.
Je t'autorise à boire. Vas-y.
Ouais. Avant. Ouais.
Tu as pas reçu de formation aux armes.
Tu as pas reçu une formation Est-ce que
tu as reçu une formation contre les
interrogatoires ?
Non, pas du tout.
Alors, j'ai entendu dire que tes boss
quand tu travaillais dans ton cabinet
ont suspectaé que tu avais collaboré. Il
t'avait interrogé. Oui,
la DGSE tu'avais pas formé à à
intoxiquer si on te chopait. Est-ce
qu'il y avait un filet
pour venir te chercher ?
Non, pas du tout.
Tu étais complètement C'est-à-dire que
si tu avais été toppé
à Jersy avec des photocopies sous le
bras,
Oui.
c'était terminé. Ben oui, en fait la
seule personne qui m'a un peu je dirais
renseigné, c'était la personne qui
l'informaticien qui m'a dit si
l'informaticien m'a dit "Bon, si jamais
on te force à à donner le code pour
avoir accès à ta clé, bah en gros euh
trompe-toi pendant cinq fois, quoi."
C'està dire même si tu te prends des
claques, vas-y quoi, tape cinq fois à
toute vitesse. Tu fais un par exemple,
tu tapes un entrée, un entrée, entré. Du
coup euh en quelques secondes, ça y est,
la clé se détruit, enfin à l'intérieur.
Et la deuxième chose, c'est il m'a dit,
j'en parle dans le livre, surtout tu ne
prends rien euh tu ne hackes rien sur
ton lieu de travail. Alors, ça veut pas
dire ne pas piquer des des dossiers ou
faire des photocopies, mais en gros, tu
vas pas te commencer à à piocher
directement dans les ordinateurs
parce que sinon tu te fais repérer,
tu te fais repérer très vite, hein. Puis
surtout, moi j'ai pas une formation de
de hackur alors peut-être je te
demanderai mais
peut-être que tu demanderas aux autres.
OK. Euh donc débriefing, remonter
d'information. Là, tu leur fais remonter
de l'information de première main. Oui.
Sur la finance internationale, sur de
l'évasion fiscale, en gros sur quelques
petits problèmes que la finance peut
nous créer. C'est ça. Est-ce que tu les
as trouvé vraiment très intéressés par
ça ?
Oui, euh ils étaient très intéressés.
Après, ce qui est très dur et ce qui est
aussi une frustration importante, c'est
que tu ne sais jamais ce que deviennent
tes informations. Donc, il se peut très
bien que ça aille pas très loin. Euh, et
puis j'aimerais aussi préciser que en
fait,
est-ce que tu es vraiment sûr que tu as
bossé pour la DGSE ?
Oui, je suis vraiment sûr d'avoir
travaillé pour la DGSE. Oui, oui, oui,
oui.
Parce que c'est toujours ça le problème.
C'est une excellente question. Mais non,
je j'ai travaillé, j'ai j'ai eu la DGSE
au téléphone et j'ai ensuite j'ai eu les
officiers traitants pendant pendant 5
ans. Euh pendant ce pendant 5 ans.
Ouais.
Après ce que je peux te dire en tout cas
on parlait tu parlais d'évasion fiscale.
L'évasion fiscale évidemment
c'est c'est ce qui est le plus connu du
grand public concernant les les paradis
fiscaux mais c'est qu'une partie de des
fraudes qu'il y a dans les paradis
fiscaux parce que les paradis fiscaux
ils sont utilisés euh pour énormément de
choses puisque c'est un endroit par
définition totalement opaque. Donc c'est
utilisé pour faire des liquidations
frauduleuses à distance. Euh par
exemple, bon bah tu as une entreprise
comme une usine en France comme
Samsonite à une abaumon qui est
extrêmement rentable, tu fais croire
qu'elle est pas rentable, tu envoies le
le l'usine ensuite en Chine et puis
tuorganises la la banquoute de
l'entreprise sans qu'on puisse remonter
en fait jusqu'à jusqu'au fond
d'investissement.
Euh donc les les les paradis fiscaux
sont utilisés pour ça et le fait
d'ouvrir plein de sociétés gigones qui
sont très compliqué donc tu arrives
jamais à savoir qui est derrière la
société enfin derrière toutes ces
sociétés et ça ils le font pour en fait
que s'il y a une attaque juridique par
exemple de salariés ou de syndicat
n'arrive jamais à remonter si tu veux
jusqu'à ces personnes-là ou s'il y a un
fisque qui vont remonter jusqu'à eux
c'est extrêmement difficile. Donc ils
ont besoin, ces financiers ou les
politiques
ou des fois l'État a besoin des paradis
fiscaux pour asseoir sa domination.
Donc il y a les liquidations
frauduleuses, il y a aussi tout
simplement les habits de bien sociaux.
C'est-à-dire tu es une tu es patron
d'une grosse boîte, tu dis "Je vais
prendre 100 millions de ma dans la
caisse quelque part c'est ma boîte, je
fais ce que je veux." Donc tu mets en
place plein de structures assez
complexes.
Euh tu fais du délit d'initié, par
exemple, tu as à nouveau, tu es un gros
chef d'entreprise d'un d'une du CAC 40.
Euh tu sais avant tout le monde qu'il va
avoir un énorme contrat qui va être
signé, qui va rapporter beaucoup de soit
à l'entreprise. Tu montres une structure
par exemple à Jerset, Luxembourg, on
sait pas que c'est toi derrière, tu
achètes énormément d'actions avant la
signature du contrat. Tu les revends
disons les actions prennent, je sais pas
30 40 % ou 10 %. 20 % et le une fois que
c'est signé euh tu
Et ça ils arrivent pas à le voir,
c'estàd que l'AMF, l'autorité des
marchés financi c'est impossible pour
eux avoir ça. Non non, il faudrait que
il faudrait qu'on travaille qu'il
travaille en permanence avec
les les services secrets, avec des gens
en interne comme j'étais. Il faudrait un
véritable réseau
vivant et extrêmement réactif. En fait,
on pourrait faire tomber tout.
C'est pas le cas.
Ah non, c'est pas du tout le cas. Non,
non, tu rigoles. Pas du tout le cas. Ça
a jamais été aussi facile en 2019 de
truander euh l'État. Euh c'est de plus
en plus facile et les structures sont de
plus en plus simples à monter.
On a toujours trois coups de retard.
Alors, c'est assez paradoxal,
c'est-à-dire tous ces montages,
finalement, c'est assez facile si on le
voulait vraiment de savoir qui est
derrière et comment les fraude sont
faites.
Euh
et en fait, on dit qu'on a trois coups
de retard en disant "Oh, en étant des
fétistes, on va jamais y arriver et
cetera." Mais en fait, c'est très très
simple. Si on voulait véritablement
alors si les politiques s'y intéressent
pas pour le moment, peut-être que c'est
aussi pour ça que moi j'ai lancé la
plateforme avec mon frère et puis je
travaille aussi avec beaucoup d'autres
personnes en ce moment en se disant "Bon
bah l'État veut pas faire son boulot,
pas de souci, on va on va s'y attaquer
tranquillou dans notre coin et avec la
presse et aussi en attaquant
juridiquement des milliardaires et des
et des et des multinationales
françaises. C'est ce que je fais en si
tu veux, je peux donner des exemples de
On verra ça après. Je voudrais qu'on
revienne sur ta liste de courses.
Oui. cette fameuse liste de courses, ces
fameuses listes de courses euh qui
t'avaient été euh données, ce qui
consistait à intercepter de
l'information euh plus ta carte blanche
euh là où tu pouvais euh récolter ce que
tu veux.
Ouais.
Tu les as senti fébriles euh par rapport
à la à la santé au au reins de la
finance, par rapport à la santé et la
fiabilité des banques ? Est-ce que ils
t'ont posé des questions sur
les les la réalité des fonds
des banques ? Est-ce que il respectai le
protocole de balle 2, balle 3 ? Ils
t'ont posé des questions comme ça ?
Est-ce qu'ils t'ont demandé s'ils
avaient réellement le cash ? Est-ce
qu'il est-ce que tu les as senti
Oui, totalement. Absolument.
Vraiment fébrile sur
Absolument fébrile. Alors, faut savoir
que moi quand je commence à travailler
pour eux, c'est en 2007. 2008, il y a la
crise de ce prime, on se prend la
finance se prend une gifle. Et euh après
les services, donc j'en parle dans le
livre, il y a notamment une liste de
courses extrêmement techniques que j'ai
gardé parce que était tellement
technique et complexe que j'ai pas
réussi à résoudre les demandes qui
m'étaient
un exemple
euh un exemple bah tout simplement
prouver que les grandes assurances les
grands groupes d'assurances français,
les grandes banques françaises
provisionnit suffisamment d'argent. Donc
là je reviens
en cas de choc en cas de crise
financière. Donc là, je rejoins ce que
tu disais.
Est-ce que il respectait
l'État français ? La DGSE voulait savoir
si les banques françaises et les
assurances respectaient la régulation,
les les lois, c'est-à-dire balle 2,
enfin balle 3 maintenant, excuse-moi. Et
et sollevabilité 2. Solvabilité 2 donc
c'est pour les assurances, c'estàdire
les assurances doivent mettre de
l'argent de côté et balle 2, c'est les
banques doivent mettre de l'argent de de
côté. Euh et en fait moi quand j'ai reçu
cette liste de courses en 2011, j'ai été
atterré parce que je me suis dit ça
c'est incroyable. Moi, petit Maxime,
dans mon coin, euh on me demande, l'État
me demande en gros, est-ce que tu peux
nous dire au fait si les banques
française ne truent pas ce qu'ils
doivent mettre de côté ? C'est-à-dire en
fait défendre les en cas de en cas de
crise financière être capable de de
protéger les actifs des des épargnants.
Et c'était d'autant plus intrigant voir
comment dire enfin plus qu'intrigant si
tu veux c'est que je me suis dit comment
ça se fait que les régulateurs français
comme l'AMF ou la CPR
n'ont pas d'infos
non n'ont pas d'infos. Ils ont forcément
des infos.
Mais ça veut dire que les infos qu'on la
MF, la SCPR ne ne satisfont pas l'État
français.
En terme de confiance, c'est de valider
l'information.
Exactement. Oui. Donc ça pour moi ça a
été un choc. C'est ça a montré aussi à
quel point la DGSE avait confiance en
moi avec toutes ces années. dire c'était
des bon après il y a des des aspects
beaucoup plus techniques donc j'en parle
dans le livre sur les les fonds de
où où il me demande de de de d'infiltrer
enfin de rencontrer de de trouver des
Français pour infiltrer le fond de donc
fond attends fond économique de
sollevabilité
financier qui était un fond qui a été
créé après la crise de subrime parce
qu'on voulait donc de 440 milliards
d'euros si je dis pas de bêtises
avec ou sans effet de levier. sans effet
de levier et si je dis pas si je me
trompe pas et 85 milliards qui avaient
été prêtés à l'Irlande qui était
toujours en en mauvais point. Euh donc
il voulait placer un il m'avait dit
"Est-ce que tu peux nous trouver un
profil à l'intérieur pour qu'on
surveille de l'intérieur ce qui est
comment l'argent va être enfin comment
comment ça se passe au sein de ce fond
qui est qui est basé au Luxembourg. Donc
ça c'est quand je travaille au
Luxembourg.
D'autres détails sur la liste de courses
? Ça c'était un détail dans la liste de
de courses. Euh
donc c'était euh
c'est tu vois en fait la en fait c'est
assez incroyable. Tu vois l'état qui est
tu as l'impression qu'il est extrêmement
fort. Il il est extrêmement fort et en
même temps il est il est d'une d'une
faiblesse incroyable quoi. C enfin ce
genre de question m'a montré je trouve
le le la fébrilité la faiblesse de
l'État
en slip.
En slip ? Ouais. Ouais si tu veux.
Ouais.
En slip.
Ouais. Ouais. C'est dommage parce que
s'il y a si on se tape un choc euh les
banques vont peut-être pas pouvoir et on
va peut-être on va peut-être se taper un
effet domino. Est-ce que tu as confiance
dans la finance internationale pour la
capacité de résilience en cas de choc à
l'heure actuelle en 2019 ? D'après ce
que tu peux voir quand tu vois la Dodge
Bank, la Dodge Bank, ils ont dû te
demander des informations dessus, non ?
Sur la
tu la vois un peu calenchée comme ça là.
Oui, la Dutch Bank. Oui, déjà. Oui.
Alors déjà depuis, je peux plus dire
exactement quoi sur la Dutch Bank, mais
je pense déjà depuis 2009, il déjà il
flippait déjà sur la Dutch Bank euh et à
juste titre sur tous les les actifs
pourris que la cette banque détient.
Euh
qu'est-ce que je perdu la
Je C'est normal, ça fait partie du jeu.
Je te repose une autre question. Euh ils
ils t'ont prévenu que peut-être euh là
où tu bossais, il y avait peut-être
d'autres services, d'autres puissances
étrangères que tu allais peut-être te
faire repérer. Ils t'ont prévenu
peut-être de ça ou pas du tout.
Non, ils m'ont pas prévenu mais enfin on
on en discutait si tu veux mais ils
m'ont pas dit fais attention. Euh par
contre j'ai détecté, j'en parle aussi
dans le livre une espionne russe qui
travaillait pour le le cabinet d'avocat
Oier et
tu l'as détecté. Bon pas elle s'appelle
comment ? Anastasia c'est ça ? C'était
pas ça mais en fait il y avait déjà il y
avait un petit peu de rumeur sur sur
l'île tout simplement. On était on
trouvait très bizarre qu'elle était
parachutée nulle part à un très gros
poste euh pour s'occuper d'un énorme
portefeuille de de clients russes dans
lequel il y avait de rue Pascal
milliardaire proche de Poutine. Et en
fait, il s'est avéré après quelques
vérifications qu'ils font avec le
hacking quand il hack les serveurs que
ils ont dit "Oui, c'est une espionne."
Et j'ai suivi entre guillemets son
parcours parce qu'à une de mes dernières
officiers traitants en Lux quand j'étais
au Luxembourg m'a dit m'a même donné des
nouvelles si tu veux sur cette espion
m'a dit bah ensuite elle est partie à
Lond puis ensuite on a perdu sa trace
pas cherché à la baiser
alors moi excuse-moi je je excuse je
suis vraiment de la vieille école je
suis pas à vouloir baiser les les nanas
je suis désolé
pourquoi dans ton livre on a
l'impression que tu baises tout le temps
non
alors disons que oui bah j'étais
célibataire Donc je j'ai j'ai rencontré
quelques femmes.
C'est quoi quelques femmes ?
Je peux pas te dire. Je compte vraiment
pas. Enfin franchement
c'est incomtable.
Pardon ?
Ça tu les comptes plus, c'est ça ?
Non non pas du tout. Non je sais
peut-être 7 6 7 8 je sais pas.
En 7 semaines.
Non mais non mais non. Euh
et puis non, puis c'était à une époque,
c'est maintenant je suis vraiment je
suis pas c'est pas du tout euh voilà, je
suis avec quelqu'un et ça se passe très
bien.
Tu veux pas lui faire peur quoi.
Mais euh Non, puis les les femmes que
j'ai rencontré, j'ai beaucoup d'estime
aussi pour ell si tu veux. Donc euh
tu
as pas fait ça consciemment pour les
infiltrer ?
Euh je savais qu'en allant avec elle,
j'allais avoir des informations, mais il
y avait aussi de l'estime et il y avait
du sentiment quand même. C'est pas genre
français quoi.
Oui, si tu veux. Voilà. Oui, il y avait
il y avait du sentiment. Oui, il y avait
du respect évidemment.
Comment tu faisais pour les approcher ?
Bah, quand tu es dans toutes ces soirée
dans dans les restaurants ou quand tu
vas au théâtre, dans ces groupes
d'avocats, bah c'est très simple. En
fait, c'est c'est des gens en tout cas à
l'époque c'est c'est des gens qui ont la
trentaine d'années
qui sont célibataires pour la grande
majorité, qui ont pas d'enfants, qui on
qui ont beaucoup d'argent. Même les
avocats gagnent assez bien leur vie
là-bas évidemment et donc ça sort en
permanence. Donc
ça a pas des numéros de Excuse-moi, je
vais parler trivialement, mais ça a pas
des numéros de tapin, ils font pas des
soirées tapin ou des choses comme ça.
Non non non non. Alors là non
Ger c'est soft.
C'est soft. Non non c'est pas
c'est pas Londres.
Non non c'est pas Londres. Alors il y
avait des avocats qui prenaient de la
cque évidemment mais moi c'est
En quelle quantité ?
Pardon ? Je peux vraiment, je sais qu'il
y a un avocat, il en prenait de façon
Oui, enfin tous les jours quoi. Il avait
il a même pris un coup l'avion avec de
de la cque à l'intérieur et ses copains
avocats qui venait qu'allait à
Courchevel ou je ne sais qui avait pris
l'avion quand ils ont vu qu'il était né
avec de la drogue, ils ont ils ont pété
un câble enfin vulgairement parlant en
disant "Tu te rends compte, on aurait pu
se faire choper."
Donc mais oui, enfin là-bas la la
drogue, je dirais c'est pas que c'était
anecdotique, mais dans les soirées avec
les avocats en fait déjà, je pense que
c'était plus les gens buvaient
énormément. Là par contre, tu as pas
idée.
C'est quoi énormément ?
Il picolent tout le monde picole du
jeudi au dimanche quoi.
Ils ont les yeux jaunes.
Ouais, ouais, ouais, ouais. Et moi qui
ne suis pas du tout un buveur, tu vois,
une peinte, deux peintes, je suis je
suis par terre. Donc, tu fais semblant
de le coue. Mais c'est oui, c'est des
gens qui peuvent se boire. 6 7 peintes,
h peintes dans la soirée
du jeudi ou dimanche si tu veux femmes
et hommes plus les alcool fort.
Donc c'est aussi
il y a aussi beaucoup de d'inhibition
évidemment là j'enfonce une porte
ouverte à nouveau. Mais quand tu avec
ces gens-là puisque
si tu restes sobre ben tu restes avec
eux, ils finissent par te sortir
énormément de d'informations pour x
raison. Soit parce qu'il y a un client
dont ils sont pas contents qu'il les a
maltraités, qui les a mal considéré,
soit parce que euh ils sont jaloux d'un
autre collègue qui a une promotion, donc
ils finissent par dire "Mais tu te rends
compte, il a tel client, il bosse pas
machin, il fait tel truc là, il a il
vient de faire un tel document juridique
avec tel client et tu apprends
énormément." En fait, plus tu te tais,
alors là je parle beaucoup, j'arrête pas
de parler, mais en fait plus tu te tais,
plus tu as énormément d'information. Et
là-bas, j'étais vraiment l'oreille
autant avec les femmes qu'avec les
hommes. Euh
quand tu dis autant avec les femmes avec
les hommes, c'est-à-dire
en terme d'écoute, voilà. Mais pas en
terme de fréquentation, j'étais ami avec
les hommes, amis avec les femmes et avec
certaines femmes, ça allait un peu plus
loin.
Tu t'es jamais fait repérer par une
femme ?
Alors, il y a je parle dans le livre, il
y a aussi il y a il y a une de mes amies
proches euh
sur l'île qui qui a qui a suboré qu'il y
avait que je faisais quelque chose
d'anormal sur l'île.
Comment ?
Parce que elle voyait qu'en dehors du
travail, j'étais tout le temps en train
de finalement de Elle s'est rendu compte
que je collectais tout le temps des
infos quoi.
Tu compilais ?
Que je compilais. Exactement. Euh alors,
elle voyait pas ce que je compilais.
Elle vo jamais personne ne m'a vu en
train de taper sur mon ordinateur sur la
clé USB, on est bien d'accord. Euh mais
comme j'ai passé un peu de temps avec
elle euh que c'est quelqu'un de
d'extrêmement sensible et
elle elle a compris qu'il y a quelque
chose qui qui se passait.
Je reviens sur le la la fameuse clé USB,
je reviens sur le ta bécane.
Est-ce que la DGSE tuas t'a appris à à
vérifier si quelqu'un avait touché ta
bécane pendant que tu étais pas là ?
Est-ce que ils t'ont appris à vérifier
si quelqu'un avait pénétré chez toi ?
Non, non, absolument pas. Juste alors je
sais là, tu vas dire les amateurs. Non,
non, juste vraiment. Alors, par contre,
ils m'ont dit, alors là, je donne une
petite anecdote que je dont je parle
dans dans le livre. Euh,
à un moment donné, j'ai un de mes
officiers traitants même qui enfin bon
là, c'est pareil, je vais me faire en
fait non, même c'est une anecdote qui
est pas dans les
Mais en direct, tu fais attention.
Oui. Ouais, je vais pas le dire. Alors,
je vais pas le dire. Pardon,
excusez-moi, j'ai déjà oubliqué le
direct. Disons qu'il y a il y a eu des
clés USB des fois qui sont perdus, on va
dire
de toi.
Non, non, pas de moi du tout, mais de de
gens
à la city ou
qui sont perdus parce que il y a
quelqu'un qui est venu les chercher.
Disons par exemple, non, un truc tout
bête, tu es dans une colocation, tu es
jeune financier à la city, vous êtes
cinq dans un appart, tu es pas là, tu as
laissé ta clé USB dans un endroit, tu as
un cololloque colocateur qui qui vient
qui prend la clé. Bon, heureusement,
c'est crypté, mais tu vois, tu peux
avoir des
C'estd que tu as égaré des clés. Non,
moi pas du tout. Là, je te parle d'un
exemple qui m'a été dit par une personne
à DGS.
Revenons revenons à la finance. Euh toi,
tu gérais personnellement un
portefeuille.
Oui.
Mais tu as aucun diplôme pour gérer ça ?
Pour la Non, dans la finance, absolument
pas. Alors en fait ce qui s'est passé
c'est moi j'étais parti en Angleterre
bah pour apprendre l'anglais, j'étais
allé à Bristole et à Bristole il y a des
amis enfin une femme qui était avocate
qui m'a dit tiens est-ce que ça
t'intéresserait de de travailler dans un
paradis fiscal ? Alors moi déjà je
savais pas ce que c'était vraiment qu'un
paradis un paradis fiscal pardon.
C'était une notion très vague et très
floue pour moi
et comme qui était relié à je dirais à
intuitivement je me suis dit je veux
aller voir ce qui se passe dans les
paradis fiscaux. Il y a la notion de
secret qui m'intriguait et d'aventure.
Je me suis dit faut que j'aille voir ce
qui se passe là-bas. À l'époque donc en
2007 tu avais pas de livre, tu avais tu
avais pas Snowden, tu avais pas toutes
ces infos sur même sur la finance. Donc
intuitivement, je me suis dit "OK, j'y
connais rien mais je vais y aller." Il y
avait rien qui était garanti du tout.
Il t'ont proposé quoi comme boulot ?
Secrétaire, apporter les cafés ?
Alors non, non, pas du tout. Euh au
départ donc j'ai donné mon CV à une
connaissance de cet ami de Bristole qui
l'a remis donc qui était une
connaissance qui travaillait dans dans
le plus grand cabinet de de d'avocat de
l'île qui s'appelle Mouran. Cette
connaissance l'a transmis aux ressources
humaines et ils avaient besoin d'un
francophone pour s'occuper en partie.
Donc dans le dans le portefeuille qu'il
y avait, il y avait beaucoup de de
clients francophones euh pardon euh
francophones
euh et ils avaient besoin d'une nouvelle
personne euh dans cette équipe. Donc
c'est aussi simple que ça. Euh et euh il
s'est avéré que le gars ensuite qui
était le chef de mon équipe était de
Bristole. Moi je venais de Bristol, il
m'a dit "Ah, tu es de Bristole ? Super,
ah génial ! Bah je te prends, on va te
former, t'inquiète pas, tu connais rien
Finances. Pas de souci, Max, on va
t'apprendre et c'est parti comme ça.
Donc j'ai le gros avantage, même si j'ai
aucun diplôme en économie ou et cetera,
j'ai le gros avantage de d'avoir une
formation, je dirais complètement
pragmatique
de terrain
de terrain qui je trouve est la
meilleure, qui m'empêche pas maintenant
de lire des livres en économie,
d'échanger avec des potes économistes,
de mettre en place un réseau d'ailleurs
avec des économistes.
Mais j'étais formé, ça c'est le bon côté
je dirais du du comment dire des des
anglo-saxons, c'est ce pragmatisme où
ils t'apprennent de façon empirique et
assez rapidement tu
te débrouilles tout comme un autre qui a
fait 5 ans, 10 ans d'étude. Il y a pas
de souci de ce côté-là.
Donc ça consistait en quoi ? Qu'est-ce
que tu faisais là-bas ? Alors euh au
départ donc j'étais l'aide euh
de
de d'un administrateur. Donc j'ai ce
qu'on appelait un traini, donc c'était
quelqu'un qui était en formation et puis
ensuite je suis devenu comme lui euh
administrateur puis ensuite seigneur
administrateur. Et en fait
l'administrateur le travail c'est
comment dire pour schématiser.
tu as tes fonds qui sont immatriculés et
bergés en fait à Jersey ou au Luxembourg
et toi tu es là pour faire croire qu'il
y a une substance de l'entité,
c'estàdire faire croire qu'il y a une
véritable vie juridique administrative
et ça c'est fait pour que les gens qui
lancent les fonds par exemple bah les
gens les financiers qui sont en France
n'est pas de problème avec le fisque.
En fait, la substance, la notion de
substance est très importante en droit
international. La substance, c'est quoi
? C'est-à-dire, il faut il faut que le
comment dire tout ce qui est décision
d'un fond ou d'une entité
va être taxé ensuite. Donc le but des
financiers français, c'est de faire
croire que la décision est prise à Jersy
alors qu'en réalité, elle est prise en
France ou en Allemagne et cetera. Euh
c'est pour ça qu'il y a tous ces
montages et que il y a une substance,
c'està dire qu'il y a il y a un vrai
service qui est fait par ces ces
montages financiers alors qu'en fait
c'est c'est du vent, il y a rien du
tout. Tuas
tu as pas l'impression que tu as été
engagé en fait pour faire du vent ?
Oui oui si c'est ça. Bah c'est
combien tu étais payé sur place ?
Alors sur place j'ai été payé à l'époque
j'en parle aussi dans le livre 2800
pounds par mois l'équivalent donc
c'était en 2008 2009
peut-être avec le change 3002 3300 €. Il
faut savoir que la vie là-bas est
extrêmement chère. Euh quand tu es pas
de Lele et que tu es un expot euh et que
tu es un tu es un coel, c'est-à-dire que
tu es pas avocat ou pas expert
comptable,
tu vas payer plus d'impôts que tout le
monde et ton logement c'est un logement
spécifique qui va être deux fois plus
cher que tout le monde. Donc en fait sur
l'argent que je gagnais, je mettais rien
de côté
puisque mon loyer me coûtait 1200 pins.
Je mangeais, je sortais.
Euh et puis et puis je collec le maximum
d'information pour la DGSE, ça
s'arrêtait là.
Et la DGSE ne te rémuné pas ? Ils t'ont
proposé un petit bifeton.
Non. Alors, ils m'ont ensuite ils m'ont
payé mes déplacements quand
en première classe.
Non, non, en seconde classe. Euh par
contre, ils m'ont proposé à un moment
donné de rentrer dans la Banque
européenne d'investissement
en au Luxembourg et ça aurait été
j'aurais été bien payé une planque,
je sais pas, peut-être une planque à
6000 balles pour pour rien faire quoi,
pour faire la grande oreille pour eux
dans dans une institution européenne,
dans une banque européenne. Et j'ai
refusé parce que donc à l'époque j'étais
encore à Jerséy. Il m'avait un de mes
officiers traitants, enfin l'officier
traitant de l'époque m'avait proposé ça
et et j'ai dit "Non merci, je me vois
pas aller dormir au Luxembourg." Bon
après, je suis allé au Luxembourg.
Euh on m'a on m'a dit aussi euh "Mais on
comprend pas les enfin mon officier
traitant, mes officiers traitants
disaient souvent "On comprend pas, tu
veux pas d'argent, tu veux pas de
médaille.
Les superurs, ils comprennent pas ta
motivation.
Bah oui, des fois on a juste envie de
faire quelque chose gratuitement. On n'a
pas envie euh puis en plus j'avais déjà
mon salaire quand même. Je me voyais pas
en plus prendre des sous derrière. Par
contre euh quant au Luxembourg euh
ensuite quand j'ai dit à la DG ceux que
j'allais arrêter de travailler de leur
finance parce que j'en avais marre euh
et qu'ils ont voulu placer quelqu'un de
chez eux euh donc un un fonctionnaire
euh à ma place, il aurait été non
seulement il aurait reçu non seulement
le salaire que j'avais à l'époque au
Luxembourg. Donc au Luxembourg, je vais
même dire combien je gagnais. J'étais à
3200 € net par mois.
net après impôt, tout ce que tu veux.
Euh plus 13e mois, plus plein d'autres
avantages. Donc j'étais en gros à 3500
net par mois. Euh et là le gars qui
voulait placer aurait gagné mon salaire
si tu veux plus ce que la DGSE lui
aurait donné.
Combien la DGSE donne ?
Ça, j'en sais strictement rien. Je l'ai
jamais demandé. Ça m'intéressait pas.
Qu'est-ce qu'il faisaient tes parents
pour que tu sois aussi pur que ça ?
Ouais, pur. En exagérons rien quand
même. Disons mon père, ça a été un ce
qu'on appelle un établi. Alors pour la
petite histoire, un établi, c'est
quelqu'un dans les années 60 70 enfin 70
plus qui donc mon père avait fait des
études de d'histoire est allé travailler
10 ans en usine, il était maouiste, il
était assez haut placé dans dans un
parti interdit maiste qui avait été
interdit par
comment il s'appelle ? Giscard destin.
Donc mon père était en clandestinité
pendant 10 ans et a vécu avait rien un
très très très pauvrement avec ma mère.
Donc il y avait ma sœur vraiment avec
que dal et un peu comme un moine même si
même si était marié. Et ensuite moi je
suis arrivé il avait en 78 il avait fini
je crois en 74 75. Donc si tu veux,
c'est cet engagement si tu veux dans
dans la famille, il est extrêmement
fort. Euh et puis avant lui, il y avait
mon grand-père donc qui a été résistant
à 19 ans dès 40 euh qui a sauvé des
juifs puisqueon il y a des juifs de
Hollande qui sont nous ont contacté un
Alex Landet qui nous a contacté, un
enfant qui l'avait sauvé. Il était dans
il a il a tué des nazis, faisit beaucoup
de enfin il faisait beaucoup de choses.
Ensuite, il était capturé par les nazis
et c'est il s'est sauvé. Il a rejoint
ensuite les forces françaises libres en
Afrique du Nord. Il était goumier et il
a été blessé notamment par NCLOBU. Et
ensuite, il est revenu avec ses potes
marocains
quand ils ont débarqué en France. Donc
c'est pareil si tu veux la notion de
pour en venir aussi à mon grand-père,
cette notion de de bah de servir les
autres évidemment gratuitement. Les
c'est c'est ce qu'il y a de plus beau,
c'est ce qui donne un sens à enfin c'est
un des sens à la vie évidemment.
Alors, une petite anecdote peut-être là
qui va être peut-être pas très sympa
pour pour ma définte grand-mère, mais je
sais qu'il y a une histoire qui qui
tombe dans la famille que ma grand-mère
donc mon grand-père passait des juifs si
tu veux entre qui venait de Hollande ou
d'ailleurs sur son dos, c'est un athlète
contrairement à moi. Il passait donc le
doux hein donc la rivière entre la
Franchectée et la et la Suisse. Et en
hiver où là où le dou était le plus bas,
il il est passé femme et enfant sur son
dos et de l'autre côté pour pour aller
en Suisse pour pour qu' qu'il soit
protégé là-bas. Et ma grand-mère lui a
hurlé dessus plusieurs fois apparemment
mais rends compte tu as même pas demandé
de l'argent et cetera.
Euh donc non, il fait il a il a pas il a
pas demandé d'argent ni mon père quand
il a été établi et et moi non plus ce
qui pour moi était une une suite
logique.
La Franche Compté, il y a des gens bien
à Bes Franche Compté. Oui en fait c'est
vraiment un terro libert. Bah c'est
libertaire, c'est là qui est né à
Besançon le socialisme utopique. Je
pense même que c'est encore plus vieux
que ça. Je pense c'est vraiment enraciné
peut-être depuis des centaines voir
peut-être depuis les séquenes, la tribu
gauloise, j'en sais rien. Et il y a une
un souci enfin en tout cas jusqu'à ces
dernières années d'égalité
véritablement. C'est un peu on parle de
temps en temps de régionalisme.
Alors la Franche Comte est pas très
connue mais ça fait partie de son
régionalisme. En réalité, il y a ce
souci de d'égalité. Euh
donc il y avait Proudon qui est de
Besançon qui a été c'est un vrai
Byzantin, tu as Considérant, tu as euh
j'en oublie un ou deux. Donc tu en as
plusieurs vraiment qui ont été formés à
Besançon et qui ont créé en fait
l'anarchie quoi. Enfin le le mouvement
anarchiste.
Et grâce à ce mouvement anarchiste, on a
ben toutes ces coopératives ensuite qui
sont nées, toutes ces l'idée de mutuel,
l'idée d'égalité véritable entre les
hommes et les femmes de de bon même si
Proudon, il y a des choses à redire sur
sa vision des femmes malheureusement
mais
cet aspect d'égalité est vraiment ancré
en Franché. On on considère, on
conseille aussi l'iser. Ils sont bien
dans l'iser.
Tous les peuples montagnards en général
où il y a un climat un peu rude, ils
savent se serrer les coudes quand il
faut se serrer les coudes.
Surtout à mout.
Ouais.
Mout ça envoie.
Bon parenthèse fermée. Revenons à nos
moutons. La DGSE, la finance. Maintenant
que que tu es rentré, que tu as fait ton
coming out, ils ont essayé de te
rappeler, te proposer une petite soirée
où ils t'ont dit "Tu viens plus en
soirée".
Ah non. Alors moi j'étais en en relation
avec eux euh donc je travaillais pour
eux jusqu'à 2012 et après j'étais encore
en contact jusqu'à février 2013 avec eux
quand j'étais revenu en France. Pour ça
que tu as sorti une vidéo en 2014 sur ta
chaîne YouTube avec 14 vues.
Ouais, avec 14 vues. Oui, c'est ça. En
fait, je voulais passer euh avec les
moyens du bord comme tu as pu le voir
des informations sur
alors c'était sur quoi en 2014 ? Euh
c'était sur Myth Romené ou c'était sur
Ouais, voilà. C'était
donc c'était pour aider les les salariés
de d'énom. Euh
revenons au contact avec la DGSE. Oui,
donc la DGS depuis 2 février 2013, j'ai
plus de contact. Euh je sais avec la
sortie du livre, je le sais par
l'intermédiaire de deux journalistes
très différents que Guinel.
Alors, il y a il y a Guinel mais il y en
a un autre aussi que j'ai vu
dernièrement. Il
a des petites lunettes
alors
qui seint les cheveux un peu en roue.
Non. Euh alors en fait, ils étaient deux
du 2e journal que j'ai vu et un des deux
cit la première fois que je voyais et
euh et ce ce bon, j'ai pas donné les
noms, mais disons ils ont la 2ème
rencontre enfin les les journalistes
m'ont dit que les les Big Boss étaient
vraiment pas contents euh voilà de ce
genre de révélation. Euh je pense que ça
fait leur fait pas une mauvaise pub. Je
pense que c'est voilà, il faut pas non
plus exagérer.
Enfin, ça montre qu'ils sont quand même
dans les paradis fiscaux qu'ils ess ils
essaient de faire Alors, j'ai j'ai fait
une rencontre qui est bizarre euh suite
à la sortie du livre après la vidéo avec
Denis Robert, j'ai un type avec un
profil très très curieux, un gros gros
chef d'entreprise euh
dans les pays étrangers euh start-up,
tout ça, tout ça, euh qui m'a contacté
entre deux avions euh à Paris en me
disant "Est-ce que je peux vous
rencontrer ?" C'était extrêmement
rapide.
Et je lui ai dit dès qu'on s'est vu, on
me dit je suis très content de vous
rencontrer mais enfin vous êtes pas du
tout le genre de profil. On sait pas du
tout que je suis sectaire mais je me
suis dit c'est bizarre pourquoi ce type
veut me rencontrer et en fait dans le
message qu'il m'a dit on il m'a dit on a
des amis en commun on a aucun ami en
commun et c'est vraiment une une grosse
pointure dans ce qu'il fait.
Et ensuite à la fin de l'entretien qu'on
a eu ensemble, il m'a dit "Vous savez
euh
vous savez attends que je je
euh c'est vous savez la c'est les les
c'est c'est la politique qui fait qui
décide, c'est pas les fonctionnaires."
Je me suis dit "Mais pourquoi il me dit
ça ? Enfin enfin pourquoi il me dit ça
?" Donc j'ai compris qu'il y avait un
petit message peut-être qui après
peut-être pas après c'est peut-être le
hasard, c'est peut-être une personne qui
était sur mon chemin à ce moment-là.
J'en sais
partons de cette hypothèse.
Oui.
Les fonctionnaires, ils font bien leur
taf. Non, ils essayent maximum.
Certain Oui, certains. Oui.
Et alors quand on quand il te dit c'est
les politiques qui gèrent, ça ça te pose
pas un problème pendant la guerre ?
Heureusement qu'il y avait des
fonctionnaires qui avaient dit "O là, on
va pas faire la politique, nous on va on
va continuer d'être fonctionnaire
jusqu'au bout et puis on va ralentir
histoire de leur mettre des bâtons dans
les roues."
Oui, c'est vrai. C'est vrai. Euh oui, je
trouvais que c'était un peu une excuse
aussi facile. Je pense que moi je
considère qu'en fait tout à chacun un
fonctionnaire ou pas fonctionnaire ou ou
citoyen, salarié, enfin on peut faire
beaucoup de choses à sa petite échelle.
Et et alors pour prendre l'exemple de la
DGSE, pas for on n'est pas obligé de
révéler des choses sur le travail de la
DGSE, mais peut-être qu'on peut à
certains moment donné infléchir sur
certaines décisions sur les les big
boss. Peut-être qu'on peut essayer de
voir la un peu la vie autrement, quoi,
pas seulement accepter les ordres.
Qui c'est qui met les big boss à leur
tête ?
Bah beaucoup les politiques, hein,
évidemment. je veux dire les les donc
euh et malheureusement enfin
malheureusement bon après je je suis
vraiment comment dire pas quelqu'un
d'important pour pour pouvoir parler de
ça ou avoir un avis spécifique dessus
mais je trouve que c'est un peu dommage
de mettre à la tête de la DGSE par
exemple des gens qui sont des anciens
préfets ou euh ou des diplomates. Enfin
les diplomates pour moi c'est c'est un
peu des gens qui suisent la langue quoi.
Je veux dire c'est des gens qui aiment
s'écouter. C'est pas forcément, bon, je
suis peut-être un peu méchant, mais
c'est peut-être pas forcément les
meilleurs profils à mettre à la tête de
la DGSE, quoi.
Tu sais comment on les appelle nous ?
Non.
Les Rochers Suchchard.
Ah d'accord. OK.
Les Rochers Schard. Tu connais pas les
Rochers Schar ? Les soirées de
l'ambassadeur.
Dis-moi, la DGSE, elle a pas le droit
d'enquêter sur le territoire français,
mais elle elle enquête sur les boîtes
françaises à l'étranger.
Est-ce qu'ils t'ont posé des questions
par exemple sur les montages que d'Assit
? Est-ce que les jamais
Non non non non. Ça ça les intéressait
pas. Par contre, ce qui à un moment
donné euh ils m'ont demandé assez
rapidement euh je crois que c'est en
2008 euh pourquoi à l'époque la Farge
voulait délocaliser euh
en Syrie ? Pas en Syrie. Ouais. même si
après il y a eu le problème évidemment
avec la Syrie, mais son siège alors à
l'époque il était question de Tsoug en
Suisse et après si je dis pas de bêtises
c'était en fait Zuri qui a été choisi.
Et donc voilà, c'était le type de
question que alors ça c'était pas dans
la liste de course mais c'était un coup
un officier traitant m'a dit "Mais à ton
avis pourquoi est-ce qu'ils veulent
mettre
la comment dire la boîte là-bas à Tsug
?" Mais je dis "Mais enfin Tsug c'est
moi il faut que je fasse attention mais
ce que je vais dire donc je vais rien
dire. Mais qu'en règle Ouais, en règle
générale,
c'est un beau village.
C'est un beau village. Voilà.
Voilà. C'est c'est le chocolat est bon.
Exactement. Et et
et il fait bon y vivre.
Voilà. Et les femmes sont souriantes.
Ouais.
C'est pas là. Non, c'est pas là qu' on
retrouve des banquiers habillés en cuir
avec des pommes dans la bouche morts au
fin fond de leur leur de leur chambre.
Non non, ça ça c'est Genève. Ça
c'est Genève. Oui oui. Non non ça
tiens ça t'a pas posé de questions qu'on
retrouve des temps en temps des
financiers.
Alors là c'est pareil j'en parle aussi
dans le livre à un moment donné. J'ai un
un collègue qui qui était en train de
devenir un ami italien qui s'appelait
Alessandro qui était en fait donc c'est
des quand j'étais à Jers c'est tu
travailles c'est des ce qu'on appelle
des des open plan donc si tu vois tout
le monde c'est des grands des bureaux
ouverts et donc Alessandro s'occupait de
d'un énorme portefeuille à côté de moi.
C'était quelqu'un que qui je plaisantais
énormément qui était extrêmement
intelligent
et un jour on l'a retrouvé en bas d'une
falaise en fait. Donc je je on se quitte
le vendredi, salut à lundi et cetera. On
le voit pas lundi, on le voit pas mardi,
mercredi. Tout d'un coup, les les big
boss du département nous disent, ils ont
avec des têtes pas très heureuses en
nous disant
"Réunissez-vous dans telle salle, on a
quelque chose à vous à vous dire." Et en
fait, ils nous ont dit "Alexandro a été
retrouvé mort en bas de la falaise à
Jersey dans le nord de l'île."
Euh alors tout de suite, bon moi sans
aide par ano, je me suis dit bon tiens
bizarre quoi, qu'est-ce que Alessandro
pourquoi est-ce qu'il a fini en bas de
de l'île, enfin en bas de pardon de
peut-être accident. Donc il y a une
enquête, apparemment c un accident, il
serait tombé du haut de la falaise.
Et ça a été pour moi un moment un
peu comme à Jibouti avec les juges, des
fois on les trouve comme ça.
Ouais. et ça a été un moment très
violent pour moi émotionnellement.
Je enfin c'est vraiment où je pleurais
enfin on était enfin tous les potes qui
avaient autour je veux dire ça était dur
pendant vraiment 3 semaines un mois de
enfin on était dans le déni moi je enfin
on pensait enfin même c'est idiot dire
mais qu'il allait revenir quoi. Enfin je
sais pas c'était c'était tellement été
violent de de pu le revoir.
Et puis aussi il y a d'autres histoires
comme ça qui sont arrivées. un un fin
enfin deux associés euh de Lille euh qui
était un qui était d'ailleurs un parent,
un type avec qui je bossais, qui a été
sans doute assassiné euh et le deuxième
associé de ce type là, c'est est parti
très vite dans les Émirats arabes unis
au même moment et puis il y avait une
question de blanchiment d'argent en même
temps. Enfin, Jers, voilà, c'est pas
tourpo, c'est pas que la belle carte
postale tranquille où tout est beau. Et
il y a aussi des risques évidemment
à Jersety. Et les Anglo-Saxons sans
vouloir généraliser,
c'est quand même, ils sont moins rigolos
sur certains points que les Français.
Les Français sont plus doux, plus
compréhensifs. Le le le gergien,
l'Anglo-saxon, s'il y a un problème, ben
voilà, on te met au bout du on te met au
fond du ravin. Dans le livre aussi, je
parle d'un copain avocat, un gros gros
avocat d'affaires qui a été laissé pour
mort dans la rue. Euh, il était en plus
rugby faisant des arts martiaux, enfin
bon, le gros costaud. Euh, il revenait
d'un avec plusieurs autres gars copains
de d'un mariage qui était tous rugby de
d'un mariage. Donc, ils étaient assez
méchés.
et ils sont fait tomber dessus par
derrière avec des bouteilles. Donc le
copain s'est fait tomber dessus avec le
une bouteille qui qui qui s'est écrasé
sur son crâne par derrière. Ensuite, il
y a des personnes qui l'ont écrasé qui
ont fait ce qu'on appelle d'estamp quoi,
son visage sur le sol. Euh après donc il
a il a mis des enfin énormément de
temps. Enfin c'était extrêmement
compliqué. il a eu beaucoup de
dépression et on a dû lui refaire le
visage, mettre des plaques dans le
visage et le type qui avait fait ça,
donc la bande de jeunes, c'était des
vrais gens de Lil parce que lui c'était
pas un gars de Lil, c'était un gars de
de Bristole. Euh, ils sont fait attraper
plus on a retrouvé aussi le jean sur
lequel il y avait le sang du copain
dessus et cetera. Euh et la justice en
fait le monde de Jezulier, le chef de la
le procureur
de Lille et le big boss de Lille en fait
sont deux frangin. Donc en terme de
conflit d'intérêt, bonjour quoi. Et
comme il y a une sorte de
comment dire de d'équilibre que le la la
l'oligarchie locale veut garder, en fait
le gars qui enfin l'équipe qui avait qui
avait laissé pour mort cet ami dans la
rue n'a absolument pas été condamné. Il
a été relâché.
Euh voilà, c'est le genre de de petite
histoire qui te permet de mieux
comprendre aussi le le périmètre et le
de de de l'île et l'histoire de de
l'île. C'est ça peut être extrêmement
violent.
Est-ce que tu as vu passer genre de
l'argent de la mafia, de la drogue, des
rétrocommissions,
des choses comme ça ? Même de l'argent
français qui utilisait qui était utilisé
pour des rétrocommissions.
Alors tu tu le vois pas tu vois pas de
valise hein. C'est fini les valises
depuis les années 80 90. C'est fini.
Je parle en ligne.
En ligne ? en ligne, il y a des
structures au Luxembourg euh qui étaient
plus que suspectes, tu vois, des
fondations italiennes avec on tu sais
pas qui est derrière qui investit euh
qui met de l'argent de façon conséquente
50 100 millions dans un fond
d'investissement
luxembourgeois.
Tu sais pas qui est derrière quoi.
Enfin, soit-disant que tu sais avec la
ce qu'on appelle les gens de la KW qui
sont censés vérifier qui est derrière,
mais en réalité, tu n'as tu n'as pas de
preuve absolue du tout. Donc les paradis
fiscaux sont des grandes blanchisseuses.
Bon là c'est pareil tout le monde le
sait hein, des grandes blanchisseuses de
d'argent sale avec l'argent propre des
des des banques françaises, des
assurances.
Tout ça c'est mélangé ensemble et ça
repart dans le système.
Tu tu parles de de d'évasion fiscale euh
tu parles de tout ça mais l'optimisation
fiscale c'est légal. C'est c'est légal.
C'est peut-être pas moral.
Alors ça Alors ça c'est le grand lavage
cerveau de ces dernières années par
certains médias français. Je m'attendais
un peu à la question. Euh l'optimisation
fiscale, il y en a une effectivement que
tu peux faire en France. Tu quoi ? Bah
par exemple euh tu décides pour euh
payer moins d'impôts de dire bah tu vas
te mettre en je sais pas en société
civile au lieu de te mettre en SAS donc
tu as tu as des moyens de payer moins
d'impôts. Ça c'est l'optimisation
fiscale. dans le choix que tu as de la
structure de ta boîte ou bien tu
décides, tuas tu as plein d'usines
et puis à la à la la tête de comment
dire propriétaire de ces usines, tu mets
une société, la maison mère et et le ce
qu'on appelle le régime société Maire
Fle va te permettre de faire remonter
des dividendes
vraiment sans payer beaucoup d'impôts.
C'est le moins qu'on puisse donc ça
c'est l'optimisation fiscale. Alors
est-ce que c'est
c'est légal ?
Ça c'est c'est légal. Est-ce que c'est
moral ? Ça c'est on peut en discuter, on
peut en parler, on peut le combattre
aussi. Mais l'optim l'évasion fiscale
c'est très simple, c'est utiliser des
structures pour faire partir le cash en
dehors du pays. Donc Belgique,
Luxembourg, Jerset, de Lawer, Hollande,
Irlande,
Irlande, Hollande,
enor Non, j'ai pas vu de structure qui
est passé pas enor, c'est vraiment tout
petit. Même pas non plus. Turquie
Kaikos Turky
Kaikosamas Bamas oui oui, pardon. Tu dis
quoi ?
Angia.
Angia, non. Euh et après il y en a
tellement. Qu'est-ce que je pourrais
ouest ?
Non, qu'est-ce que je pourrais te citer
vraiment ? De lower, énormément de
lower, énormément Luxembourg
Islands. Alors là, voilà, on en parle
pas. Euh,
bon, ça me reviendra mais ou il y a
toute une panoplie qui est qui est
utilisée. D'ailleurs, les les paradis
fiscaux ont besoin d'eux entre eux, ils
s'entraident. Donc, chacun a un peu son
sa particularité. Le Panama, le
voilà le Panama aussi et chacun son
traite. Ils font aussi des rencontres
entre avocats pour voir comment ils
peuvent faire des structures qui qui
peuvent faire passer l'argent d'une d'un
d'une juridiction offshore à une autre.
Il se couvre
il se couvre mutuellement
pour toi.
Ah mais totalement mais c'est organisé
c'est pas que pour moi, c'est organisé
de la sorte et le disent les avocats
GERZ vont te le dire. On va dire voilà,
on va teleting au Caillement pour voir
avec eux comment euh on peut faire
remonter de l'argent des montages le
plus facilement possible avec eux.
C'est payé combien un avocat ?
Ouh là, un avocat sur l'île de Jerset à
l'époque hein. Donc je pense que là ça a
dû bien grimper. Tu as un million pin à
l'année tranquillou. Euh alors sauf les
petits moi que je fréquentais qui sont
plus peut-être aux alentours des 100000
100000 mais dès que tu es parteneur tu
es au minimum
en dehors des bonus et des dividends des
gens passent et des meilleurs. Tu as un
million de pince tous les mois qui
tombent enf pardon tous les ans.
Excuse-moi. Je
euh c'est pas non plus des grosses
sommes. font des gros coups si tu as des
moments donné euh où ils peuvent, tu
vois, par exemple, ils ont
ils vendent certaines structures et ils
multiplient le il multiplient par tr par
qu ou par plus leur ce qui ce qui gagne
normalement.
Ce ceux que tu as pu rencontrer,
ils sont dans quel état d'esprit ? Quel
état psychologique ? Ils ont ils ont
quelle vision des choses ? Pour eux,
c'est tout à fait normal de tordre la
loi parce que c'est légal.
C'est c'est ce qu'ils disent. Oui,
c'est ce qu'ils disent. Oui.
Ah ça a pas changé alors ?
Non non ça a pas changé effectivement.
D'orsur ce qu'il faut dire tout
simplement c'est que sont des ils ont
vendu leur souveraineté en fait aux
riches. C'est-à-dire que ils vendent aux
riches un vernis de l'égalité, un
artifice de l'égalité pour faire croire
que tout ça est légal. Alors c'est
totalement illégal. Au au mieux c'est un
abus de droit. Donc c'est du droit qui
est utilisé de de façon illégale et au
pire c'est totalement illégal et c'est
de toute façon à chaque fois illégal.
Euh donc non, il se tous ceux que j'ai
croisé, surtout les gros boss mais pas
que même les petits avocats de bas
étage. Il se ou les experts comptable ou
toutes les professions, les banquiers de
tout ce qu'on mange,
tout ce qu'on mange ou les même les
petites mains de la finance pensent
qu'ils sont supérieurs aux autres. Les
autres sont idiots, sont stupides, ils
comprennent pas.
Le salarié de base français, il est
idiot, il est pas assez intelligent.
C'est pas le cas.
Non, c'est pas le cas. Il est de bonne
foi. On peut tout le monde n'est pas
Pourquoi est-ce
Non mais tu as raison mais pourquoi
est-ce qu'on pourquoi est-ce qu'on
devrait à chaque fois imaginer le pire
quoi ? Pourquoi est-ce qu'on devrait
imaginer que que tu as des gens qui
prévoient le pire et qui et qui suent
tout l'argent
enfin et qui font des montages illégaux
à tous les niveaux en permanence.
Et dans leur comportement de tous les
jours ou de de soir, est-ce que tu vois
ils ont des conduites addictives en
particulier ? addiction énormément. Euh
bon bah les addictions
sport aussi non ?
Oui effectivement beaucoup de sport
beaucoup tous les jours. Alors déjà
muscu, tout ça beaucoup de sport et ce
qui est très particulier, tu vas voir
des gens qui vont avoir une conduite
très sportive jusqu'au jeudi et du jeudi
au dimanche ça va être des épaves. Alors
tu les vois avec leur leur costard
machin sur mesure et tout et ça va être
des épaves parce que moi je les ai vu,
j'étais avec eux, j'étais chez eux. tu
les vois euh vraiment ce qu'on dit
vulgairement déchiré à l'ouest pendant 3
jours, déprimé, gravement déprimé. Donc
c'est tu passes vraiment c'est des
cycles, c'est des cycles qui sont
courts, c'est des cycles, tu vois, de
chaque semaine. Euh donc même moi, je me
posais la question comment même
physiquement ils arrivaient quoi. Je
sais pas comment ils arrivent à 60
avec la drogue évidemment. Donc euh
beaucoup de boissons comme je te disais
à nouveau addiction à la boisson et
comme tout le monde enfin tout le monde
la grande grande majorité picole de
façon euh enfin est alcoolique du coup
euh euh dans le pays où tout le monde
est aveugle le enfin je veux dire
le bornier roi
le bornier roi euh donc il voit même pas
qu'ils sont alcooliques si tu veux
puisque tout est excuse pour
pour se mettre la race
question d'internet
oh là je vais être taquin euh de agent
libre. Quel est le problème avec Zug ?
Optimisation fiscale ? OK, mais il y a
autre chose. Bah, disons que ça ça peut
être un endroit intéressant pour
pour placer des caisses noires de
rétrocommission si tu veux.
Ah, autre question. Euh, est-ce qu'il y
a un comité d'éthique en interne chez
dans dans ce type de boîte
dans les cabinets d'avocat ? Oui, c'est
ce qu'on appelle la la la enfin pas
d'éthique mais de KYC. on est sont
censés vérifier que c'est on travaille
dans la légalité. Alors ça c'est pareil,
c'est un vernis pour les journalistes
étrangers, pour l'OCDE, pour toutes
toutes les institutions.
Euh mais c'est c'est à mourir de rire.
Alors une question de Saint-Pixel ou
on lui passe le bonjour d'ailleurs et un
humour extraordinaire. Alors vous
précisez page 105 de votre livre que la
DGSE ancre ses origines dans l'histoire
de la résistance et se vit aujourd'hui
comme le dernier rempart en cas
d'effondrement de l'État. Effectivement
question. N'y a-t-il pas un problème de
perspective entre le PDG culturellement
sans attache fonctionnant au niveau
transnational et la DGSE qui défend un
territoire avec une psychologie issue de
la deuxème guerre mondiale ?
Ah oui, ça c'est une très longue
question mais excellente.
Euh effectivement, on a totalement
raison. Euh quelque part, on a des très
beaux idéalistes à juste titre qui se
considèrent les les successeurs de la
résistance, mais en même temps tout ça
c'est du romantisme parce que légalement
ils sont pas les ils sont pas le dernier
rempart de contre le pire. Je veux dire,
il y a rien qui le qui le dit dans la
loi. Et pendant donc je rebondis
là-dessus dans le livre justement, j'en
parle effectivement
pendant la formation de 3 jours que j'ai
par plusieurs personnes de la DGSE, j'ai
eu un petit comment s'appelle là les
petites présentations PowerPoint ou
PowerP
où euh euh
qui d'ailleurs qui a été fait par le
petit Jean enfin le pseudo que je donne
he c'est euh de de la personne qui m'a
appris à faire les filatures où il dit
que la DGSE elle l'héritier de de la
résistance, qu'ils utilisent les mêmes
techniques, pas que sur la filature, sur
beaucoup de choses et que la résistance
et que la pardon la DGSE et le le
dernier rempart contre le pire. Euh donc
c'était assez intéressant, je trouvais
de mettre cette anecdote si tu veux
parce que euh ça c'est pas du tout prévu
par la loi.
Autre question euh y a-t-il un dossier
effondrement économique sur le bureau de
la DGSE ?
Tu es peut-être pas au courant de ce qui
se passe au courant de ça.
Tu as jamais visité le parquet ? Non
non
non non.
Euh autre question. Les jets privés de
Jers et fiscalisé, c'est pour faire quoi
? Valise de cache, on s'en fout. Pardon,
désolé pour la question.
Ah oui. Euh euh Comprends-tu que
certains puissent penser que tu as été
naïf ?
Oui, absolument.
Euh
j'ai été donc quand je je suis j'ai
proposé mes services à la DGSE, donc
j'avais 28 ans euh et je considérais que
je pouvais aider mes concitoyens dans
monter les informations.
Non mais tu te rends pas compte, tu es
pas issu de leur parcours, tu as pas été
recruté par eux. Ils ont dû halluciner
quand tu as tapé leur porte.
Ouais, je pense qu'ils ont dû bien
rigoler. Ils ont dû se taper sur la
jambe. Ils ont dû bien rigoler.
Puis après, ils ont dû se rendre compte
qu'ils étaient complètement aveugles.
Mais bon, après ça a du moins les fait
rigoler.
Et euh attends, excuse là. Du coup, euh
est-ce que tu étais naïf ?
Oui, naïf. Euh et puis euh je pense
qu'avec bon euh dans au cours des années
de de
travail avec la DGSE, de
complexification des questions qui me
posaient des listes de courses, je me
suis rendu compte à juste titre que les
informations que je donnais n'allaient
pas servir mes concitoyens du tout. au
contraire, malheureusement allit
enrichir les milliardaires français et
les multinationales françaises. Aller
donc accélérer destruction du tissu
social, les inégalités et donc ça va
énormément travailler ça comme tu t'en
doutes.
On est on est en guerre économique, il
faut protéger nos florons
non
et nos milliardaires.
Ouais. Non, ça c'est une excuse de
évidemment de milliardaires pour se
cacher derrière l'opacité pour faire
tout ce qui toutes les magoues qu'ils
ont envie de faire. Et je considère que
la guerre économique, elle commence déjà
par ces milliardaires et qu'ils la font
contre nos concitoyens. En fait, la
guerre économique, c'est pas tant déjà,
c'est les pays étrangers, mais pour moi,
c'est déjà ces milliardaires
multinationales qui la font contre
nous-même parce qu'ils utilisent des
artifices de droit qui à mon sens
d'ailleurs faut se poser la question,
quelle est nature réelle de ce droit ?
Est-ce que c'est encore du droit ? parce
que c'est un droit parallèle qui ne sert
qu'à qu'à frauder. Euh donc pour moi le
le la guerre économique commence avec
eux. Alors je suis pas un guerrier, je
vais pas aller me battre contre eux. Je
pense qu'on peut le faire de façon
pacifique en faisant des actions
juridiques contre eux. Si tu on en
reparlera. C'est pour ça que j'ai lancé
des actions contre eux.
Quoi ?
Alors euh
donc avec via le le billet de la
plateforme avec mon frère, on a attaqué
le milliardaire baigné.
Comment il s'appelle ton frère ?
Alexandre. Donc Alexandre Naï moi et euh
donc on a attaqué au tribunal de
commerce de Paris Emmanuel Beigier le
milliardaire, je sais plus, il est dans
le top 8 là, top 10 des milliardaires
français avec sa famille parce que le ce
grand monsieur ne publie donc les
propriétaires de l'actalis ne publiait
pas euh la plupart de ses comptes
contrairement à ce qu'il disait dans la
presse en disant
c'est normal secret des affaires, tu te
pas compte, tu les exp si non non, tu as
l'obligation quand tu es genre de
société de publier tes comptes avec le
turnover avec les les qui fait et en en
fait il était en totale illégalité c'est
passé en commission d'ailleurs
parlementaire
aussi aussi avec Bigard et Ruffin
d'ailleurs était dans cette commission
parlementaire
François Ruffin. Donc moi je me suis
rendu compte que en fait malheureusement
la maison maire de l'actalis qui
s'appelle BSA et d'autres sociétés ne
publiait toujours pas de compte. Donc on
l' attaqué au tribunal de commerce et
avec l'avocate, on lui a demandé 10000 €
d'astreint jour si euh il ne publiait
pas ses comptes. Donc il a repoussé, il
s'est dépêché de repousser d'une semaine
le procès hein vite fait bien fait quand
il a reçu les assignations en bonet du
forme. Et un jour avant euh le
le procès, il a publié les comptes. Donc
la première fois depuis enfin la
première fois depuis toujours pour
certaines sociétés comme BA. Euh donc ça
c'est une première chose.
Il y avait du Windows Dracing dans les
comptes ou pas du tout ? Alors, je vais
être
C'est quoi le window dressing ?
Le window dressing, là par contre, moi
ça me parle pas comme pas grave, on
reviendra après. Continue. Euh donc en
fait pour aussi développer un peu sur
l'actalis, à l'origine j'avais été
mandaté par la confédération paysane
pour enquêter donc j'ai fait un rapport
sur les comptes enf l'argent qui part
euh vers en fait les paradis fiscaux de
de l'actalis qui part en fait vers la
Belgique puis ensuite le Luxembourg.
Donc j'ai donné un rapport à ce sujet-là
qui a été ensuite transmis au Parquet
national financier le PNF. qui euh a
s'est saisi de ce rapport et a demandé
la DNEF qui est la Direction nationale
des enquêtes financières de faire une
perquisition le 28 juillet dernier dans
les
euh comment dire les locaux à l'aval de
de l'actalis. Alors bon, je parle de la
DNEF dans le livre euh comment dire ?
C'est des bras cassés. Alors, je veux
pas dire bras cassé parce qu'il y a
forcément des gens
question
non parce qu'il y a des gens bien
forcément mais en tout cas ce qui dans
le le le le chapitre dans lequel je je
parle à DNF où je les rencontre quand je
leur propose mes services pour et que je
leur donne des informations sur des
milliardaires français ils prennent rien
alors que j'ai des des informations
extrêmement tangibles sur l'évasion
fiscale à grande échelle. Il me disent
"Oui oui super, on va on va on va vous
reconacter." Ils ont jamais
"Écvez-nous un petit mail."
Non mais j'aurais tout donné en dur.
J'aurais donné tous les documents.
Un procès verbal là-dessus. Alors
justement dans le livre, j'en parle, ils
ne ils ne prennent pas de de procès
verbal et tout de suite ça me choque
parce que moi je dis tout de suite donc
il y a un boss qui est là avec son
subalterne.
Comment c'est quoi son nom ?
Alors on va pas dire les noms. Bon il y
a
on dit les noms ici.
Ouais alors le boss il sa pas
plus il est payé avec notre argent. Non
c'est un fonctionnel.
Non mais non disons le en plus le boss
c'était pas présenté. Bon j'ai le nom du
subbalter mais ça sert à rien de de de
l'embêter. Je préfè
tu peux pas leur donner un petit bâton
merdeux là. Non, je préfère donner un
bâton merdeux comme tu dis si bien ou à
des milliardaires, c'estàd au gros au
gros puissant si tu veux. Mais par
contre le chapitre sur la DNF,
pourquoi tu t'attaques pas ? Euh, je
vais pas dire au relais parce que ce
serait mal les qualifiés, mais
pourquoi pourquoi tu montres pas qui ne
fait pas son travail ?
Ben ça, je le je le mets dans le livre,
je donne
mais avec des noms.
J'ai donné un nom quand même mais
continue.
Ouais, mais je veux pas le dire en
ligne. Enfin bon.
H
mais tu vois, je suis tellement
enthousiaste que je me perds à chaque
fois làdedans. Donc la on va dire les
informations que tu leur as emmené, pas
de procès verbal.
Pas de procès verbal. Donc
c'est un gentleman agreement.
Ouais, c'est ce qu'il me dit. Donc le le
patron là, le le big bus me dit "Mais
non, on fait pas de procès verbal, c'est
un gentleman agreement entre nous." Je
le regarde, je me dis "Mais attends,
c'est bon quoi. Je veux dire, on est en
France dans un état de droit, pas de pas
de preuve, pas de trace, super quoi. Je
file des documents qui permettent
potentiellement de ramener des centaines
de millions d'euros à la collectivité.
Même pas de trace si je passe. Bon,
j'avais pris des petites photos deux
trois trucs, tu me doutes en rentrant
parce que voilà, c'est après formation
de la DGS oblig.
Oui, merci. La DGS oblige. Euh et puis
ensuite pour être bien sûr que aussi
j'ai certaines preuves que j'aurais bien
donné les documents, je me suis assuré
de
enfin de qu'on soit
couvrir tes arrières. ouvrir mes
arrières. Euh
donc ils ont ils ont
j'en avais parlé d'ailleurs à Denis
Robert, le directeur de
du média
du média donc la web télé média. Je suis
passé chez lui pour présenter le livre.
Ensuite, on a fait une vidéo sur Bon là
je digresse un petit peu là mais
on a tout notre temps.
OK. sur l'évasion fiscale de BFM TV donc
qui appartient en groupe Altis avec Ah
excuse-moi
l'optimisation fiscale. L'optimisation
fiscale de
pas de diffamation. Attention les ma
langue à fourché en fait c'est je c'est
donc de enfin c'est c'est voilà c'est
donc l'optimisation fiscale de BFM TV
entre autres vers le Luxembourg. Euh
donc on avec le la web télé le média, on
a j'ai donné toutes les informations et
j'ai travaillé avec de super
journalistes en plus avec Denis Robert
mais avec Yanis et puis Théophile et ils
ont mis ça en musique pour que ça soit
bah compréhensible parce que c'est c'est
un peu pénible, c'est un peu chiant.
Voilà. Donc on a sorti cette information
là à propos de remonter vers le
Luxembourg et euh et ça pas été repris
par les enfin si ça été repris par
certains médias mais alternatifs et par
Téléama non
et par Téléama bon qui est pas
alternatif mais par Téléama et le patron
de Next Radio TV donc c'est la holding
dans laquelle il y a BFM TV qui
s'appelle
Alain Veille a dit à ce moment-là est
sorti du est sorti du de la forêt en
fait alors que en disant c'est n'importe
quoi, mais en ne répondant à aucun
argument technique qu'on avançait,
absolument rien en disant que le CSA,
alors mort de rire que le CSA est au
courant de ce qui se passait de y
compris des montages. Je vois pas ce que
le CSA a faire avec les montages
fiscaux. Le fisque oui mais le CSA enfin
bon bref, il était franchement
Excuse-moi mais enfin excusez-moi mais
enfin moi on a rigolé quoi franchement
sans sans
Merci merci.
Je te coupe.
Oui.
Euh ils essayent de faire leur boulot.
Tu trouves qu'il bossent bien ? Alors
pour revenir à voilà pour rebondir
excuse sur Ber donc dans cette vidéo qui
a été faite on a le média a interviewé
un type qui est super qui s'appelle
Vincent Dreuset qui est syndicaliste à
Bery qui est vraiment un type top qui
est très technique qui a montré
qu'effectivement les éléments euh
comment dire l'artifice
financier enfin les structures qui
étaient utilisées permettaient de faire
remonter de l'argent c'était
on va dire de l'optimisation fiscale. Et
ensuite à la fin de ce petit reportage,
il y a une personne encore de Bercy dont
a la voix a été modifiée qui dit
qu'effectivement ils ont beaucoup de
choses concernant l'optimisation fiscale
qu'ils ont énormément d'infos mais que s
arrêtaé à chaque fois par
le haut quoi.
Donc ça j'étais très content et honoré
de voir qu'il y a quand même des gens à
Bercis
bah qui sont pas contents de de ce qui
se passe et qui sont des très bons
techniciens qui veulent faire du bon
boulot et on les empêche de faire du bon
boulot.
C'est qui ont les big boss, les
politiques.
Les big boss, les politiques. Oui, c'est
ça.
Et donc pour revenir sur donc sur
l'actis toujours, donc il y a eu donc ce
rapport voilà, je crois qu'on a fait le
tour, excuse-moi. Donc voilà. Après donc
cette donc on
pour l'actalis en fait ça va pas
s'arrêter là parce que pour
je veux m'assurer que la DNF fait bien
son travail et ne va pas envoyer
direction nationale pardon des enquêtes
financières qui dépendent Ber n'envoie
pas cette investigation sur les comptes
de Lactalis dans les limbes. Donc on va
sortir, je je vais pas dire qui est
derrière on, mais on va sortir à un
certain moment énormément d'informations
sur l'actalisme.
J'en viens à la question d'Internet.
Qu'est-ce qui garantit votre sécurité
aujourd'hui après ces révélations ? Les
personnes éclaboussées ne
pourraient-elles pas vouloir se venger ?
Ben la protection c'est le fait d'être
ici. Plus je suis dans les médias, plus
c'est aussi tous les tous les amis que
je me fais dans dans des milieux très
différents, le monde syndical. J'ai eu
la grande chance d'avoir énormément
maintenant de syndicalistes avec la
sortie du livre qui me contacte. Donc il
y a un réseau de syndicalistes très
forts qui est en train de se développer.
Heureusement des vrais.
Pardon ?
Des vrais ?
Oui, des vrais. Des vrais.
Tu comprends pourquoi je dis des vrais ?
Oui. Oui, on se comprend. Je pas en
parler là, mais on se comprend. Euh
et puis euh aussi de journalistes. Alors
moi j'étais j'ai jamais forcément eu les
journalistes dans mon cœur mais là je
suis obligé de reconnaître qu'il y a des
Pourquoi tu les avais pas dans ton cœur
?
Alors euh parce que il y a une certaine
presse, je trouve qui cirent vraiment
les pompes. C'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire au pouvoir en place quoi, tu vois.
Et ça euh quelque part euh
enfin ils prennent ils ont une
responsabilité dans
ce le côté autoritaire que prend le la
conduite de l'État. Ça c'est pour moi
c'est pas acceptable. Euh après, tu as
plein de journalistes et pas que dans
les médias alternatifs qui cherchent
vraiment à faire leur boulot et qui
prennent des risques et et là je suis
vraiment il y a il y a un réseau de
d'amis de copains à copines qui se
développent et le but c'est euh bah
qu'on puisse avec aussi d'autres amis
des économistes des chercheurs en
investigation économique qu'on leur
donne un maximum d'informations sur des
affaires mais qu'on leur fasse aussi
plus tard ça c'est prévu des formations
pour trouver l'information dans les
bases de données y compris dans l'open
data, comment analyser le but c'est de
démocratiser les révélations. Alors, je
peux pas me poser en tant
qu'inquisiteur. Moi, je suis pas là pour
dire, je suis pas un justicier, dire si
c'est bien ou si c'est mal. Et je
considère que la forme est aussi
importante que le fond quand on révèle
des choses, faut le faire de façon
neutre. Euh, mais il y a un tout un
réseau de de potes qui est en train de
se mettre en en marche, on va dire, en
rigolant, euh de gens qui le font
gratuitement euh
en mouvement. En mouvement, voilà, c'est
mieux. Et d'ailleurs là bah petite
anecdote là en septembre pendant 3 jours
en Bourgogne avec des potes, on va se
réunir économistes des activistes pour
voir comment on peut s'entraider,
comment on peut systématiser les
actions.
Alors là, c'est plus sur la finance mais
on on lance aussi des passerelles dans
d'autres domaines parce que je suis très
sensible aussi à la cause animale et à
l'environnement.
Euh mais on veut déjà commencer par ce
noyau dur, plus les journalistes qui a
un 2è noyau. Et euh
donc la la passerelle là-bas qu'on qu'on
a qu'on a faite avec mon frère euh
dernièrement, c'est avec 214
l'association euh
Sébastien, si tu nous entends
et et Brigitte Brigitte Gautier euh que
je remercie.
Donc en fait à l'origine après
l'actalisme, je me suis dit bah autant
qu'on continue. Je veux dire quelle
grande multinationale est dans
l'impunité, ne publie pas ses comptes ?
parce qu'il y a person quand je dis
Punité, il y a personne. L'État ne vient
pas les chercher pour les obliger à
publier les comptes alors qu'il y a une
commission parlementaire qui leur a
demandé de publier les comptes. Euh ben
je me suis dit le deuxième qui était
dans la commission parlementaire c'était
Bigar qui avait été donc du groupe de
viande le premier groupe
multinational qui de vente de viande en
France qui produit je crois 70 % de du
steak en France. Et je me suis dit ben
on va les attaquer eux juridiquement, on
va les assigner.
Euh donc on les a assigné bah pour sur
on les a assigné par trois fois. Bigar,
Charal et euh non, j'ai la troisème j'ai
désolé, j'ai un trou de mémoire. Sokopa,
je crois. Euh donc la
c'est pas je crois attention,
excuse-moi. Oui. Euh oui, c'est SCOPA.
C'est c'est ces trois Excuse-moi. C'est
c'est ces trois entités là.
et euh au tribunal de commerce donc
Quimperlet, Anger et Créteille euh pour
les obliger à publier leur compte. Alors
si les publi avant, très bien, mais s'il
est publi euh je prendrai le plaisir de
les analyser ensuite et de voir ce qu'il
y a dedans et d'en parler avec les
journalistes. Euh et ça ça s'est fait
grâce à un partenariat. Alors moi je
suis assez fan de partenariat, ce que
j'appelle partenariat informel avec des
des amis. Euh donc là, c'est un
partenariat qui s'est fait sur contre
Bigar euh grâce à à une journaliste qui
est une pote qui s'appelle Ines Lero que
je salue qui est qui euh qui a sorti un
livre dernièrement, une BD très bien
faite euh s'appelle Les algues vertes,
une histoire interdite. Euh et puis avec
une autre personne qui est lanceur
d'alerte sur la viande qui s'appelle
Pierinard, qui avait lancé un livre sur
l'omerta de la viande
et qui a une société qui s'appelle le
bœuf d'herbe.
Oui. Et donc en fait, c'est Inè qui m'a
mis en contact avec j'ai proposé, est-ce
que ça te dit qu'on lance une action
parce qu'elle avait suivi l'actalis m'a
dit "Ouais super, je suis je suis
partante." Alors au départ, faut savoir
que c'est nous qui payons notre poche.
Par exemple, moi l'attaque contre
l'actalis avec mon frangin, ça nous a
pris 3000 € tu vois. Tu tu balances 3000
balles dedans de tes petits sous ensuite
comment tu vis maintenant ?
Alors comment je vis ? Euh
vis pas le ensuite hein. D'accord. Je te
mets une je te coupe un peu.
Oui.
Donc com comment tu vis ? Qui te paye ?
Qui me paye ? Alors en dehors du
bénévolat que je fais dans les actions
ou pour certains travails pour certains
certains travaux pardon pour certains
syndicats, il y a des groupes de
salariés ou des syndicats qui me
mandatent pour faire des rapports
d'investigation
qui sont ensuite donnés à des avocats
par exemple dans des liquidations
frauduleuses ou des choses comme ça pour
demander des dommages intérêt au
tribunal au TGI donc tribunal de grande
instance. Donc à ce moment-là, moi comme
je fais passer beaucoup de temps, je
leur demande que c'est utilisé par
l'avocat pour dans les contreconclusions
pour attaquer, je demande à être
rémunéré. Donc je suis en en libéral
et
auto-entrepreneur
en auto-entrepreneur effectivement. Et
j'utilise une partie de ces de ces sous
ensuite moi pour avec mon frère
Alexandre donc pour euh pour alimenter
euh mon petit activisme
dans des attaques juridiques ou dans
d'autres choses. Euh donc je vis euh
assez euh
fichement
assez simplement. Oui.
Des enfants ?
Non, pas d'enfant, pas de voiture, euh
pas de toit, pas de propriétaire,
tout petitte maison euh ridicule.
Euh je vis très bien, il y a pas de
souci, il y a pas de misérabilisme et je
pars je prends pas l'avion et je pars
pas à l'autre bout de la planète et je
prends pas de vacances. Enfin, quand je
prends les vacances, c'est dans les va
où j'habite.
Magnifique. Le revenons à
voilà à Bigar. Donc Bigar, donc je avec
Iness Lero, elle me dit euh OK ben moi
aussi je vais mettre de ma poche, je
veux faire l'action avec toi. Et puis
elle me dit tiens tu contacte Pierre de
ma part, peut-être qu'il peut
t'intéresser. J'appelle Pierre, il me
dit "OK, super, je suis partant, faut
combien ? Heureusement, on est une
avocate qui fait des prix militants si
tu veux." Donc déjà aussi, ça permet de
de Et puis euh
et Ines me dit "Mais pourquoi tu
contacterais pas Brigitte Gautière de
114 ?" Et puis je me dis "Ouais super,
moi j'adore 214, je les suis et tout."
Et bah j'étais surpris Brigitte, je lui
ai envoyé un
un projet enfin un petit mémoie
au téléphone, elle a dit "Banco, on y
va, on y va avec vous." Et en plus
généreusement, elle a dit "On va payer
les frais d'avocat et les frais de
huissier sur toutes les actions." Et là,
je la je la remercie.
Et ensuite bon, on a on a travaillé le
communiqué de presse tous ensemble et je
lui ai dit "Bon ben quand vous êtes
prêts, on appuie sur le bouton V, on
envoie."
Bon, autre question internet.
Et Dieu dans tout ça ?
Et Dieu dans tout ça
? Est-ce que tu as la foi quand tu fais
tout ça ou c'est simplement par
patriotisme ? Non, pas de fo
pour tes valeurs chrétiennes ou tes
valeurs de ce que tu veux ?
Alors, j'ai
J'aime bien le
euh
Tu n'as pas d'amis imaginaire ?
J'ai pas d'amis imaginaire, désolé. Euh
disons, j'ai la foi si tu veux. Euh je
considère qu'on a tous en fait une
mission dans la vie. Le but de la vie
c'est de découvrir sa mission euh comme
toi bah de monter la chaîne YouTube. On
a sa mission et une fois qu'on a trop
qu'on a le plaisir et la chance de
l'avoir découverte. D'ailleurs, on le
sait très tôt en réalité. On le sait
depuis qu'on est presque enfant de ce
qu'on veut faire en réalité. Moi, je me
rappelle déjà enfant de ce que je
voulais plus ou moins faire. Et une fois
que tu
que tu fais les bonnes rencontres qui te
disent "Bah oui, vas-y grand, si c'est
ton but dans la vie, vas-y, c'est porte
pas de jugement moral sur sur ton sur ce
projet." Et ben il y a il y a tu as plus
de peur parce que tu dis mon but il est
défini, je sais où je vais et rien ne
peut me faire peur. Alors c'est je suis
pas cassecou pour autant, je suis
vigilant, je suis pas une tête brûlée.
Euh mais les menaces ou quoi que ce soit
ou les procès, alors là c'est vraiment à
chaque fois au contraire, je trouve
c'est très positif et c'est une façon de
c'est comme de faire du du de la boxe du
sparring. Du sparing, c'est une façon de
de se renforcer tout simplement.
Tu as eu des menaces de qui ? Des procès
de qui ? Ah non, pour l'instant j'ai eu
des mini menaces genre on va vous
attaquer en diffamation. Alors ça, j'en
eu un paquet
par qui ?
Alors qui m'a dit ça dernièrement ?
Alors dernièrement c'était pour un petit
truc donc je vais pas en parler ça vaut
pas la peine disons. Ah oui l'actalisme
m'avait dit qu'il allait m'attaquer en
diffamation quand j'avais sorti
l'article dans Marianne enfin c'est moi
qui a donné avec avec Laurent Valdigue
on avait sorti enfin quelque chose. Vous
attaquez machin. Bon bah les 3 mois sont
passés grand il y a toujours pas eu
d'attaque. Enfin ça fait maintenant ça
fait 2 ans je crois ou un an et demi.
Enfin
donc il y a des grands groupes comme ça
qui disent on va vous attaquer. Il y a
eu qui d'autre dernièrement à part
Lactéis ? Je peux plus te dire mais bon
autre donc revenons à la fois ta
motivation.
Oui à la fois donc une fois que tu as
cette bah tu as cette foi. Oui. Enfin
c'est une foi mais sans sans
sans aller à l'église ou sans être à la
mosquée ou sans aller à la synagogue si
tu veux. C'est une fois que il y a
quelque chose de grand qui est là, qui
nous dépasse euh et puis que on est tous
des alors je vais peut-être faire rire
les gens mais qu'on est des frères
humains et
et qu'on est là pour pour s'entraider.
Moi là-dessus,
c'est peut-être ça être français, non ?
C'est peut-être ça être humain en
réalité. C'est c'est ça serait
intéressant de d'arriver à ça en tant
qu'être humain.
Alors, autre question d'internet. Est-il
tenté de rejoindre Trackfin ? Non non
non là non tout ce Alors pour leur
donner des coups de main pourquoi pas
s'ils viennent de frapper à la porte et
qu'ils me disent euh non non il me fait
comme ça là non non euh enfin pourquoi
pas allons-y. Je veux dire ça
permettrait de de financer d'autres
d'autres accents juridiques. Mais euh
s'il y a des administrations qui me
demandent de l'aide oui avec plaisir sur
de ou à me voir ou à faire des
rencontres pas de souci. Comme je te dis
je suis dans des partenariats informels.
S'il faut donner un coup de main pour
aider les concitoyens allons-y il y a
pas de souci. Donc pourquoi pas trac fin
si s'ils veulent ?
On arrive bientôt à la fin de notre
interview.
Tu m'avais dit que tu tu parlais pas
beaucoup.
Ouais, c'est ça qui est bizarre, c'est
c'est le problème des grands timides. Ça
parle pas beaucoup. Puis tout d'un coup,
ils se mettent à
Je regarde, je suis en train de de de
regarder un peu les questions qui sont
passées. Euh euh le comité d'éthique, on
a passé euh on fait beaucoup de clin
d'œil dans le chat des questions, les
gars.
Euh on va revenir sur le fiducial.
Une question d'internet. Peut-il nous
parler de la société fiduciale ?
Peut-être encore
euh alors pour Fid du ciel. Donc oui euh
alors je vais peut-être pas trop
développer pour certaines raisons, mais
ce que je peux dire c'est que dans un
des autres projets aussi, un petit
projet alternatif qui est en train de se
monter que je suis je paye avec auprès
d'une infographiste, on va sortir des
grandes fresques euh d'une quinzaine de
milliardaires français et de
multinational où euh donc c'est assez
joli je pense et je mettrai pas pas que
en exposition moi aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux pour voir
comment l'argent circule, on va dire, et
ma fille du ciel sera dedans.
Si je dis euh le renseignement, c'est un
métier de roi fait par des truants,
est-ce que ça te parle ?
Oui, tu l'avais déjà dit à l'in juillet,
non ? Si je me trompe pas,
euh de roi fait pour les truants,
fait par
fait par les truant
par détruant.
Par détruant. Ouais, ça me parle.
Mais j'ai pas d'autres choses à dire.
Oui, ça me parle. ton ton état
psychologique. Est-ce que tu as euh
Autre question d'internet,
est-ce qu'il a pas l'impression d'être
schizophrène ?
Non. Par contre euh j'en parle dans le
livre, à un moment donné quand j'étais
sur euh sur jersy, j'ai fait un un
burnout parce que j'étais euh quand tu
es en roue libre comme ça entre
guillemets, tu passes ton temps à
travailler et à côté tu passes encore
ton temps à travailler pour collecter.
Donc à un moment donné ça faisait un peu
trop. Donc donc c'était le moment où je
me suis remis en cause et et
aussi c'était un questionnement qui a
permis de me dire il faut que je quitte
la finance et et le renseignement qui
qui n'apporte rien. C'est pour ça que je
suis revenu en France pour aider
directement les enfin je directement les
les salariés ou ou les syndicats ou les
les personnes les personnes qui ont
besoin d'aide.
Autre question, tu vois l'avenir du du
monde financier, comment ? Est-ce que tu
penses que on va au carton ? Est-ce que
tu penses que
on est en état d'esanteur ? Quand
Christine Lagarde dit que la BCE va
pouvoir parer
pour moi, c'est vraiment secondaire.
C'estàdire que pour moi ce qui est
vraiment important c'est la crise
écologique qui va nous mettre tous à
genou là qui donc la crise financière
pour moi c'est voilà c'est il y a la
crise il y a trois il y a trois crises
en réalité qui sont là on est dedans
même si il y a la crise écologique qui
est là on le voit même ceux qui veulent
pas l'avoir et la crise sociale qu'on
essaie de cacher avec certains médias et
avec Macron mais qui est qui est là et
qui est pas qu'en France on la voit
pareil en Hong Kong dans plein de pays
autour du monde.
Euh et puis il y a la crise financière
qui commence qui va commencer à pointer.
Après, je peux pas dire quand est-ce
qu'elle va arriver parce que moi je peux
pas prédire genre de choses. Pas grand
monde peut le faire. Tuas
pas de boule de cristal.
Voilà, je suis pas de boule de cristal
mais euh c'est fort probable que ça soit
extrêmement violent comme le disent
maintenant la majorité des économistes
comme le dit un type qui est super Gael
Girot que t'a invité ici vraiment que
j'ai eu plaisir à à découvrir. J'ai j'ai
regardé depuis plein de vidéos à son
sujet.
Très bien.
Un Jésue.
Voilà. justement alors là typique de en
plus très calme et tout ça vraiment
super. Euh
autre question d'internet, s'il
considère vraiment l'état en slip,
pourquoi bosser avec lui ?
Pourquoi bosser avec lui ? Ah ah non
mais c'était au départ, moi je pensais
pas que le le l'état était en slip. Au
départ, moi j'avais la vision, l'État
est super fort, tu vois, on te nourrit à
ça des lc. Enfin bon, voilà, c'est ça
exactement.
Euh autre question, est-ce que la DGSE
lui a fourni des plans de secours pour
se préserver de sa sécurité ou même
financièrement si les choses tournaient
mal ?
Non non non, juste les juste bah si dans
l'itinéraire de sécurité les comment
dire que comment s'extraire si on est
suivi des choses comme ça mais non pas
de
pas de protection particulière.
Alors avez-vous des avis sur général
électrique Alstom ? Oui. Euh je
rencontre d'ailleurs entre autres enfin
sur notamment ce sujet, mais aussi un
autre à Scoval euh demain le secrétaire
général du PCF, Fabien Rousell et on va
parler de ça ensemble. J'ai des éléments
euh alors sur général électrique euh euh
déjà les syndicates ou certains portip
politiques ont vraiment toutes les
infos. J'étais à Surascovel, c'est pas
encore le cas, donc je vais partager ça
prochainement. Euh euh et puis euh
pour général électrique, j'ai eu la
chance d'être invité par une personne de
l'intersyndical prochainement comme
c'est pas loin de chez moi, c'est c'est
Belleforme à Beson. Enfin, je suis dans
les Vauges mais je suis très très
souvent à Besançon puisque c'est mon
lieu d'origine et donc je vais les
rencontrer prochainement pour qu'on
discute justement de d'intelligence
économique et qu'on peut-être essayer de
les aider de voir ce qui peut être fait.
L'école de guerre économique ? Non, ils
t'ont proposé de faire prof là-bas. Non,
tu rigoles avec mon profil ? Non, non,
non. Mont pas contacté. Non. Ah mais
non, ils m'ont pas contacté.
Alors euh autre question internet. Alors
allez pas trop vite les gars.
Comment il fait pour garder cette
naïveté entre parenthèses tout à son
honneur avec tout ce qu'il a vu
et ne pas être désabusé ?
B, parce que j'ai pas envie d'être dans
le misérabilisme et que je rencontre
plein de personnes incroyables en fait
euh qui sont totalement exceptionnels
dans des milieux totalement différents
euh chez les ouvriers, chez des cadres,
chez des agriculteurs, euh des
syndicalistes, enfin un peu partout. Et
ça donne, je suis aussi polytechnicien,
j'en ai rencontré à midi.
Euh
et en fait ce que je me rends compte
enfin c'est qu'il y a il y a un
véritable réseau en fait qui est en
train de se mettre un peu dans le
silence de ces gens-là qui commencent à
je pas dire à rentrer en résistance mais
il y a un peu de ça quand même et je
suis extrêmement positif. Euh
et puis je vois aussi par exemple que
tout bon là c'est je je parle un peu
d'autres choses. Je passe un peu du du
du Cocalan mais par exemple ma petite
maisonnette dans les Vauges maintenant
au départ j'étais enfin maintenant il y
a une trentaine de potes dans les
alentours de de gens qui viennent
d'Alsace de jeunes de 25 à 40 ans enfin
voilà tu vas avoir des copains des GSI
toi
et et qui viennent d'Alsace de Suisse ou
même d'ailleurs qui qui se disent "On
veut plus vivre dans système de fou" qui
se mettent à faire du maréchage qui se
mettent à être dans l'entraide à être à
devenir artisan à à être par exemple
conducteur de de de camion mais à vivre
autrement. Donc si tu veux en même temps
euh je suis extrêmement positif quand je
vois euh euh ces réseaux qui sont en
train de se former de journalistes, de
chercheurs, de de syndicalistes,
d'ouvriers, de gilets jaunes
euh parce que moi je soutiens à fond
évidemment les gilets jaunes et aussi le
fait qu'il se battent pour la justice
fiscale. Il y a des supers gilets jaunes
à Besançon, ils font un gros boulot. Euh
donc il y a il y a je suis très positif
en fait, on est vraiment aux prémises de
quelque chose de nouveau. Euh
tu penses ?
Je pense oui. Autre question d'internet.
Euh les les gestionnaires de fortune
suisse avaient vu la la crise de 2007
venir dès 2007 en sortant les fortunes
de l'immobilier. Est-ce que les
gestionnaires de fortune ne sont pas un
indicateur de l'avis des cercles
financiers avertis ?
Alors là, je j'aurais peur si tu veux de
dire quelque chose de trop généraliste.
Donc oui, voilà, je pas suffisamment
d'éléments techniques pour euh à
apporter.
On arrive à la fin de l'interview.
Est-ce que tu vois des choses à aborder
en plus ?
Non, peut-être pour une autre fois. Et
euh de tradition, on demande de laisser
un conseil pour les jeunes générations,
une bouteille à la mer. Euh quelque
chose qui pourrait être impérissable.
quelque chose qui pourrait être
impérissable. Bah tout simplement
l'amitié, c'est-à-dire le le contraire
de la domination tout simplement. Donc
l'égalité, l'amitié, il faut y croire,
elle a une véritable importance. Et sur
les trois livres,
ben en fait c'est presque des livres de
résistance qui me viennent tout de
suite.
Euh au nom de tous les miens de Martin
Gray, résistant juif du Ghetto de
Varsovie, que j'ai lu des centaines de
fois quand j'étais enfant et adolescent.
un sac de bill de Joseph Joffo.
Euh qu'est-ce que je peux dire d'autre ?
Après, il y a plein de super livres de
gens comme Monique Pinon Charlot qui
aussi enfin qui permettent de euh Il y a
tellement de livres intéressants. Bah
disons c'est déjà ces deux livres là en
terme de résistance et puis de foi
quelque part. Si tu retournes à Jersey,
il te fouta
non, je vais pas à Gerti,
il y a eu un gros scandale avec Jersety.
Jersey a en fait, bon, j'ai fait un peu,
j'aime bien titier, j'ai fait un pied
né, j'ai avec le Jers evening Post, un
journaliste, on a on a sorti quatre
articles sur le fait que j'avais
espionné chez eux et au Luxembourg et ça
fait la une pendant 4 5 jours. Ça a été
un scandale là-bas. Le gouverneur de
Lille a dû sortir un communiqué de
presse en disant que le livre n'allait
pas arrêter les bonnes relations entre
la France et Jerset, qu'il y aurait pas
de d'investigation, qu'on allait calmer
le jeu. Puis ça a été un tel, il y a
tellement des gens de la finance qui ont
été
pas contents qu'il a dit "Bon, il y aura
quand même une enquête policière."
Voilà. Mais non, Gers non, c'est hors de
question que j'y retourne. Et tu vois
même pour la promotion membre du livre,
à un moment donné, je suis allé en
Belgique euh ça était super avec les les
copains belges là-bas de Bruxelles. Et
tu je serais jamais allé au Luxembourg,
il y a eu un journaliste de Luxembourg
qui était très sympa d'un journal
d'investigation qui est qui est venu à
Bruxelles pour me rencontrer.
Ouais, ils vont chercher à coffret quoi.
Mo, je veux pas prendre le risque en
tout cas. Bon Maxime Rena Bon, merci
beaucoup.
Je t'en prie avec grand plaisir. Merci
pour l'invitation et d'avoir rencontré,
de vous avoir rencontré.
Merci. Coupéz.
[Musique]